bon ben écoutez je pense qu'on va
démarrer puisque
on a tout le monde qui est arrivé nos 4
apporteurs sont là les invités sont là
également donc on va pouvoir démarrer la
Réunion chers collègues mesdames et
mesdames nous poursuivons ce matin notre
travaux sur la thématique santé des
femmes au travail avec les quatre
rapporteurs Annick Jacquemin Laurence
Rossignol Marie piercée et Laurence
Cohen qui sont toutes avec nous ce matin
en réunion nous nous penchons
aujourd'hui sur la question des
conséquences sur la santé des femmes des
violences sexistes et sexuelles au
travail nous nous intéressons à
plusieurs problématiques premièrement
les conséquences pour la santé des
femmes des violences sexistes et
sexuelles subies dans le cadre
professionnel deuxièmement les mesures
prises en place par les employeurs pour
prévenir ces violences et protéger les
victimes enfin la prise en compte par
l'employeur des situations de violences
conjugales ainsi que les effets de ces
violences sur les trajectoires d'emploi
des femmes
il nous apporte également dans ce cadre
de pouvoir formuler des recommandations
pour agir contre les violences ces
violences dans l'environnement
professionnel afin de protéger la santé
et le bien-être des femmes au travail
les violences sexistes et sexuelles au
travail se heurte aujourd'hui encore à
un manque de visibilité
l'ampleur du phénomène reste difficile à
quantifier en 2015 le Conseil supérieur
de l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes avaient publié une
enquête estimant que 80% des femmes
avaient été victimes de sexisme au cours
de leur vie professionnelle en 2008 une
enquête de l'INSEE avait révélé que 5%
des viols et 25% des agressions
sexuelles étaient commises sur le lieu
de travail des études plus récentes sur
ce sujet existent-elles certains acteurs
certains secteurs professionnels
sont-ils plus concernés que d'autres en
outre quelles sont les responsabilités
des employeurs dans ce domaine en
matière de prévention et de sanction
comment s'organise la prise en charge
des victimes notamment celle des coups
de santé induits par ces violences la
question de la prise en compte des
violences conjugales dans le cadre
professionnel se pose également
notamment depuis la ratification par la
France en 2021 de la convention 186 de
l'OIT relative à l'élimination et de la
violence et du harcèlement dans le monde
du travail qui instaure une
responsabilité de l'employeur vis-à-vis
de leurs employés victimes afin
d'étudier ces différentes problématiques
nous accueillons ce matin Catherine
Cavallin sociologue de la santé chargée
de recherche CNRS à l'Institut de
recherche interdisciplinaire en sciences
sociales et Pauline Delage sociologue du
genre chargé de recherche au CNRS
Florence chapert
je prononce bien oui très bien
responsable de la mission égalité
intégrée à l'Agence Nationale pour
l'Amélioration des Conditions de Travail
la date que nous avions déjà entendu au
mois de mars sur la question des risques
professionnels vous interviendrez donc à
distance madame chaperte enfin Raphaël
manière pilote de la cellule contre la
violence sexiste et sexuelle de la CGT
et membre du comique du collectif femme
mixité de la CGT bienvenue à toutes
mesdames et donc je vais laisser tout
d'abord la parole à Catherine Cavallin
sociologue de la santé
ocnrs et Pauline delache sociologue du
genre
ocnrs également qui vont donc intervenir
à devoir à vous Mesdames
merci beaucoup madame Guillon mesdames
et Mesdames et mesdames merci beaucoup
pour votre invitation vous m'entendez le
micro fonctionne correctement
oui la table est assez voilà oui
j'essaie de me hausser sur la table nous
vous remercions pour votre invitation
nous allons présenter à deux voies les
20 minutes qui nous sont impartis dans
cette intervention nous allons partager
avec vous une lecture des violences
subies par les femmes dans le contexte
du travail en nous appuyant sur les
travaux produits dans les 10 ou 15
dernières années sur les violences
fondées sur le genre nous souhaiterions
partir de deux idées structurantes la
première idée s'appuie sur une des
leçons que nous pouvons tirer du
mouvement me too ce mouvement
transnational est polymorphe de
dénonciation des violences sexistes et
sexuelles a connu de multiples rebonds
depuis son démarrage à l'automne 2017
aux États-Unis ce mouvement a touché et
continue de toucher de nombreux pays et
des populations variées mais un facteur
d'unité demi-tour réside dans le fait
qu'une partie des dénonciations porte
sur des violences sexistes et sexuelles
commises dans les relations nouées au
travail ou par le travail
que Mitou se soit ainsi exprimé comme la
voix de milieu professionnel distincts
attire notre attention sur l'importance
à accorder aux spécificités des
contextes professionnels autrement dit
sur l'importance à accorder à la
connaissance de l'organisation du
travail
en outre le fait que ces univers
professionnels très différents se
reconnaissent malgré tout dans une même
étiquette MiTo nous alertent sur la
transversalité du phénomène social de
l'inégalité entre les sexes dans le
travail
la deuxième idée dont nous souhaiterions
partir c'est celle de la dynamique
croisée entre les relations de couple et
les relations dans le travail une
dynamique croisée qui s'est développée
dans les dernières années en France
depuis la première loi du 2 novembre
1992 qui a créé en France l'infraction
de harcèlement dans les relations de
travail jusqu'à la loi du 30 juillet
2020 qui a consolidé le délit de
harcèlement qui avait créé en 2010 la
loi du 9 juillet 2010 pour la relation
de couple qui avait créé le délit de
harcèlement les 30 dernières années ont
été marquées par une construction
progressive croisée par cette dynamique
d'une législation qui sur les violences
sexistes et sexuelles étalées par des
allers-retours successifs entre le
couple et le travail
à côté de la notion de violence sexiste
et sexuelle qui s'est imposée dans le
débat public ces dernières années nous
mobiliserons la catégorie des violences
fondées sur le genre pour décrire des
violences essentiellement commises par
des hommes sur des femmes et des hommes
et essentiellement vécue par des femmes
violences fondées sur le genre caisse à
dire cette qualificatif renvoie à cette
asymétrie des expériences de la violence
et au fait que les rapports sociaux de
sexe en sont l'une des causes
principales ici nous nous pencherons sur
les violences sur le lieu d'exercices et
du travail et dans les relations de
travail ces violences peuvent être
commises par des supérieurs des
collègues des usagers d'autres
intervenants d'autres acteurs mais les
violences dans le couple peuvent aussi
venir s'immiscer dans la vie
professionnelle des victimes en
particulier si le conjoint ou un des
ex-conjoints violents est un collègue où
s'il se rend sur le lieu de travail
nous déroulerons notre exposé en deux
temps successifs pour lesquels nous
interviendrons donc toutes les deux
successivement le premier point sans
exhaustivité présentera les sources
principales disponibles en particulier
les sources statistiques et deuxièmement
nous nous
référons à ce qui concerne la lutte
contre les violences fondées sur le
genre au travail et à leur prévention en
nous replaçant et en replant cette
question dans le cadre plus large des
conditions de travail en général
alors nous souhaitons montrer que dans
les 30 dernières années au cours
desquelles la loi a changé pour
qualifier et réprimer les violences
sexistes et sexuelles au travail les
sources disponibles pour caractériser
mesurer l'occurrence d'actes violents au
travail ce sont multipliés à un manque
cruel de mesure des phénomènes succèdent
donc une abondance relativement grande
d'enquête et de chiffres pour y voir un
peu plus clair on peut distinguer trois
familles d'enquêtes
socio-démographie centrée sur le travail
ou encore sur la sécurité des personnes
donc première famille d'enquête
socio-démocratique avec notamment
l'envers en 2000 événement de vie et
santé en 2005-2006 et plus récemment
virage en 2015 qui sont donc des
enquêtes portées par le système
statistique national elle propose une
approche transversale des phénomènes
sociaux et ces enquêtes placent en leur
cœur des problématiques plutôt liées au
genre donc pour en VF et virage ou à
l'état de santé pour événement de vie et
santé
deuxième famille d'enquête celle qui
sont intéressées au premier chef parce
qu'il se passe dans le travail le
principal opérateur de ces enquêtes et
le service de statistiques ministérielle
du ministère du Travail et de l'Emploi
la DARES en collaboration avec l'Insee
depuis la fin des années 70 ces enquêtes
ont peu à peu intégré des éléments
concernant les violences après avoir de
longues dates questionner les risques
physiques chimiques et biologiques que
le travail fait courir à l'étape santé
l'intégration des violences dans le
questionnement de ces enquêtes s'est
opéré en quelque sorte de biais via des
préoccupations plus directement tournées
vers les risques psychosociaux la
première de ces enquêtes de cette des
veines des enquêtes pardon de cette van
historique travail qui a ouvert à des
analyses sur les violences et l'édition
2003 de Summaire qui veut dire suivi
médicalisé de l'exposition au risque
professionnel
dans ces enquêtes de sumère 2003 jusqu'à
condition de travail 2013 et conditions
de travail risquent psychosociaux 2016
on peut noter de nombreuses hésitations
lexicales ou disons une certaine retenue
à parler de violence la dimension
possiblement sexuelle des actes subis au
travail n'est que peu travaillé il est
par exemple impossible de
discorder distingués pardon ce qui
relève des attouchements des tentatives
de rapport forcé ou des rapports sexuels
forcés en outre la dimension sexiste de
ces violences n'a été exploité que dans
conditions de travail 2013 et les
personnes interrogées peuvent indiquer
si elles attribuent les comportements
hostiles déclarés au fait d'être une
femme ou un homme enfin troisième
famille d'enquête celle qui sont donc
intéressées par la sécurité des
personnes ces enquêtes ont été
développées en France par le ministère
de l'Intérieur en collaboration avec
l'Insee depuis la première édition de
cadre de vie et sécurité en 2006 jusqu'à
la mise en route récente en 2022 de
l'enquête VRS vécu et ressenti en
matière de sécurité
ces données peuvent identifier des actes
de violences sexuelles selon les liens
entre agresseurs et victimes et peuvent
également donner des indications sur le
lieu de survenu des actes de violence
mais en aucun cas elle ne se propose
d'explorer spécifiquement le lieu de
travail ou les relations de travail
comme espace de commission des violences
sexuelles elle ne permettent pas non
plus d'estimer le caractère sexiste des
actes qu'elles enregistrent depuis le
milieu des années 2000 ces enquêtes ont
pris une part importante au débat sur la
mesure statistique des violences en
France en particulier s'agissant des
violences subies dans le couple par les
femmes mais parce que ces enquêtes ne
peuvent apporter que des informations
relativement marginales par rapport aux
deux autres types de sources
précédemment citées nous n'en
reparlerons pas davantage dans notre
exposé et nous allons maintenant
présenter quelques résultats tirés
essentiellement donc deux virages 2015
et conditions de travail 2013
alors rappelons brièvement quelques
éléments méthodologiques concernant les
violences au travail dans l'enquête
virage
virage qui veut dire violence et
rapports de genre donc 15 ans après
l'envers virage a interrogé 27000 femmes
et hommes âgés de 20 à 69 ans et
résidant en ménage ordinaire comme dans
leur VF cette enquête questionne
successivement l'occurrence des
violences dans des sphères de vie dont
le travail
contraintes et de violences subies au
travail sont interrogés au total qui se
regroupent sous les quatre chapeaux
insultent et pressions psychologiques
deuxième chapeau atteinte à l'activité
de travail troisième chapeau violence
physique et enfin je lance sexuel sans
contact et avec contact
les questions ont été posées à toutes
les personnes interrogées qui avaient
travaillé au moins quatre mois dans les
12 mois précédant l'enquête
dans virages des questions plus
détaillées sur les violences subies
comme les types de faits les
conséquences et les recours ont été
posés donc seulement aux personnes qui
ont déclaré un seul type de fait en
ayant aussi indiqué qu'il était très
grave même s'il a été subi qu'une fois
ou une agression physique ou une
agression sexuelle avec contact dès
qu'elles ont précisé qu'il s'agissait au
moins d'un fait assez grave avec
éventuellement plusieurs événements dans
cette catégorie ou plusieurs types de
faits dans cette sphère du travail
alors quelques résultats de virage un
premier résultat et celui de la grande
prévalence des actes de violence dans
les relations professionnelles dans les
douze derniers mois les personnes
déclarant une répétition ou un niveau de
gravité tel qu'on leur pose des
questions détaillées sur les situations
vécues représentent
17,9% des personnes interrogées dans
virage parmi lesquels 20,1% des femmes
et 15,5% des hommes
autre résultat dans l'enquête virage
comme dans événement de vie et santé les
violences qui sont de loin les plus
fréquentes dans la sphère
professionnelle sont de nature verbale
et psychologiques les actes physiques ou
à caractère sexuels sont beaucoup moins
fréquents alors une manière
d'interpréter cela serait de faire
l'hypothèse que cela je des actes à
caractère sexiste dans ces actes
fréquents que sont des injures des
insultes des pressions psychologiques
des dénigrements
parmi les enquêtés ça c'est un autre
résultat qui détaille donc l'effet dans
l'enquête virale 8 sur 10 se trouvent
dans des situations de répétition les
hommes et les femmes étant concernés de
manière égale par ce phénomène le fait
d'isoler une personne au travail la
destruction de son travail
l'appropriation de son outil de travail
et l'intimidation sont les actes qui
tendent le plus à être répété enfin
dernier résultat que nous souhaitons
mettre en avant les auteurs qui
commettent les actes sont nombreux et
diversifiés
au moins 20% des victimes indiquent
avoir subi un même type d'acte de la
part de plusieurs agresseurs à plusieurs
moments différents
au passage on peut noter que ces
résultats empiriques donnent pleinement
raison à la manière dont la loi définit
le harcèlement aujourd'hui en France en
prévoyant qu'un fait peut être qualifié
juridiquement de harcèlement lorsque
plusieurs personnes le commettent
éventuellement séparément et sans se
concerter mais en ayant connaissance que
les violences qu'elles exercent sont
aussi perpétrées par d'autres agresseurs
sur la même victime
j'en viens maintenant résultat tirer de
l'enquête consacrée aux conditions de
travail donc conditions de travail 2013
donc dans cette enquête pour mesurer les
comportements hostiles sur le lieu de
travail trois catégories d'atteinte sont
prises en compte les comportements
méprisants le déni de reconnaissance du
travail et enfin les attentes
dégradantes
ces comportements sont entendus donc
comme sexistes quand l'enquêter les
attributs au fait d'être une femme ou un
homme
donc dans l'enquête
35% des actifs occupés signent à avoir
subi au moins un comportement hostile
dans le cadre de leur travail au cours
des 12 derniers mois et l'enquête vient
confirmer l'importance de la dimension
sexiste de ses attentes pour les femmes
22% des femmes concernées par ces
comportements les déclars liés à leur
sexe alors que c'est le cas de 4% des
hommes concernés au total 8% des femmes
et 1% des hommes déclare avoir subi un
comportement sexiste au travail les
femmes sont particulièrement touchées
dans les secteurs d'activité dans
lesquels dominent les travailleurs
hommes
parmi les victimes de comportements
hostiles les femmes qui exercent des
fonctions de supervision qui travaillent
dans l'industrie sur des chantiers ou en
déplacement ou qui sont exposés à de
multiples nuisances physiques
associées donc le plus souvent c'est
comportements hostiles à leur sexe
de fait lorsque l'emploi est typiquement
féminin seulement 6% des femmes et 3%
des hommes se disent victimes de
comportements hostiles à dimensions
sexistes et à l'inverse lorsque l'emploi
est plutôt masculin 15% des femmes et
seulement 1% des hommes se déclarent
concernés
alors en quoi ces résultats peuvent
contribuer à guider l'action publique
sur les violences de genre au travail
dans une réflexion plus globale que nous
allons esquisser maintenant sur les
conditions de travail plus généralement
ces enquêtes permettent d'appréhender
non seulement la dimension sexiste de
ces violences mais aussi les autres
rapports sociaux dans ce lié au travail
qui les rendent de possibles la
prévalence des atteintes dans leur
ensemble leur répétition et le fait que
les violences s'étendent souvent dans le
temps les faits ont commencé avant les
12 derniers mois pour 54% des victimes
incite les autrices du rapport du
rapport d'enquête virage à parler de je
cite risque systémique dans la sphère
professionnelle vous entériner cette
idée de violence systémique on peut
ajouter que l'immense majorité des faits
de violence dans la sphère
professionnelle surviennent sur le lieu
habituel de travail c'est le cas pour
72% des hommes victimes et pour 90% des
femmes autrement dit la survenue
fréquente de violence se caractérise
comme l'ordinaire du travail pour les
femmes comme pour les hommes même si les
actes ne sont pas les mêmes pour les
travailleurs ou travailleuses des deux
sex
les violences qui surviennent au travail
ne découlent pas simplement de relations
interpersonnelles c'est-à-dire de
rapport entre deux personnes prises
isolément elles engagent des rapports
sociaux on voit l'importance des
rapports de genre avec ce que d'en
virage et ce qui est désigné dans
virages comme la multi-vitimation
sexuelle des femmes au travail dans le
cadre du travail les femmes dans cette
enquête apparaissent en effet exposés
aux violences sexuelles commises par un
nombre important d'acteurs avec qui
elles interagissent dans leur activité
professionnelle donc multivitimations
importantes dans vos acteurs de même
d'autres rapports qui interviennent dans
les relations de travail exposent
davantage certains groupes sociaux
virages montrent ainsi une surexposition
aux violences subies dans le cadre du
travail toujours des personnes les plus
jeunes des personnes célibataires ou en
charge de famille monoparentale des
personnes ayant des statuts d'emploi
précaires comme les personnes à contrat
à durée déterminée ou des personnes en
mauvaise santé ou qui éprouvent des
difficultés financières
le travail est un espace où les
violences sexistes se déploient en
particulier à l'encontre de celles qui
se trouvent dans une position
subordonnée notamment de par leur âge de
par leur situation familiale ou lorsque
leurs conditions de vie de travail
d'emploi sont marqués par une certaine
précarité ce résultat rappelle aussi ce
que montrer l'enquête événement de vie
et santé en parlant des faits de
résonance les personnes les plus
exposées et dont l'exposition violence
entraîne les conséquences les plus
importantes pour la santé sont celles
qui par ailleurs ont des trajectoires
biographiques ou se cumulent les
difficultés les difficultés affectives
d'emploi économiques etc
les résultats que nous avons empruntés à
l'enquête conditions de travail 2013
montre aussi qu'une attention soutenue
aux relations entre les sexes au travail
quel que soit la qualité de
l'organisation du travail se justifie
par la manifestation toujours possible
de comportement sexistes l'enquête
suggère en effet que favoriser la mixité
au travail peut contribuer à limiter les
comportements hostiles sexistes
ces résultats laissent penser qu'on peut
difficilement penser les violences de
genre en les isolant des contextes de
travail eux-mêmes de bonnes conditions
de travail d'emploi ainsi que des
politiques d'égalité ambitieuses
permettraient de limiter la survenue de
telle violence se pose toutefois la
question de savoir comment mieux
prévenir les violences sexistes et
sexuelles et comment dans le cadre du
travail définir au mieux le rôle que
pourrait tenir les employeurs à ce sujet
deux points nous paraissent importants
le premier concerne l'obligation de
sécurité de résultat qui renvoie un
cadre structurant de l'histoire au long
cours de la santé au travail dans notre
pays et le second consiste à évoquer des
évolutions législatives récentes en
matière de santé au travail donc sur le
premier point sur l'obligation de
sécurité de résultat elle a été
initialement définie par la loi du 12
juin 1893 et c'est un des piliers du
compromis qui a été noué entre salarié
et employeur pour la loi fondatrice sur
les accidents de travail en 1898 et
celle tout aussi fondatrice qu'il a
suivi pour les maladies professionnelles
en 1919
lorsque cette obligation de sécurité de
résultat n'est pas satisfaite
l'employeur peut être jugé coupable
d'une faute inexcusable comme cela a été
le cas dans le en France dans les
dernières décennies en particulier pour
les maladies graves et mortelles causées
par des expositions à l'amiante il
apporte de rappeler cette obligation de
l'employeur qui ne doit pas seulement
montrer qu'il fait des efforts mais
qu'il doit pouvoir montrer qu'il a fait
tout son possible pour assurer que la
sécurité soit effectivement
garantie rappelez cela paraît utile
étant donné l'unanimité des travaux qui
montre l'insuffisance prévention des
risques pour la santé au travail
l'insuffisance reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles et
l'insuffisance indemnisation des
victimes de maladies professionnelles
donc un cadre général sur la santé au
travail si l'on souhaite améliorer la
prévention contre les risques du travail
alors il convient de rappeler cette
obligation de sécurité de résultat
contre la survenue des violences
sexistes et sexuelles de même qu'on peut
la rappeler contre les risques
biologiques physiques ou chimiques
l'employeur est dans son rôle si
l'oeuvre à la réduction efficace des
risques pour la santé des travailleurs
et des travailleuses dans l'exercice de
leur activité professionnelle deuxième
point donc par rapport à ce rappel d'une
règle générale sur la sécurité au
travail la loi récente du 2 août 2021
tant à confondre la santé des
travailleurs en général et l'état de
santé qui spécifiquement peut résulter
du travail cette loi un sport instaure
un dispositif qui s'appuie sur l'idée
qu'au fond le cadre professionnel
pourrait devenir un espace de vigilance
et de prévention sanitaire en général
c'est à dire pas du tout spécifiquement
pour ceux qui dans la santé découlent
des conditions de travail
à propos des violences sexistes et
sexuelles subies par les femmes il nous
semble que le cadre d'action doit
d'abord être celui de la prévention des
actes et qui surviennent spécifiquement
au travail en relation avec le travail
les employeurs et les collègues ne
doivent pas être investis de mission de
dépistage systématique des violences qui
surviennent par ailleurs dans la société
néanmoins les lieux de travail comme
peuvent être aussi l'école les cabinets
médicaux ou d'autres lieux
d'interactions collectives peuvent être
des espaces de diffusion d'informations
ou de documentation
malgré une banalisation persistante des
violences virages rappel aussi que la je
le cite je cite leur rapport d'enquête
la sphère professionnelle et l'une des
sphères où les violences sont les plus
discibles car il peut exister plus de
marge de manœuvre et donc fin de
citation potentiellement il peut exister
comme le montrer aussi événement de vie
et santé plus de soutien plus de témoins
les actes ont plus souvent lieu devant
témoin autrement dit les victimes
parlent ou peuvent parler peuvent
dénoncer les violences subies souvent
plus facilement que dans l'intimité des
relations familiales ou conjugales le
rôle des autres acteurs que les
employeurs nous semblent ainsi
absolument centrales rappelons aussi que
les employeurs comme le disposait
d'ailleurs en termes de supériorité
hiérarchiques la loi de 1992 peuvent
constituer eux-mêmes des agresseurs
l'intervention dans ce domaine ne donc
ne peut donc pas reposer seulement sur
eux
prévenir les violences sexistes au
travail nécessite l'intervention et la
formation des employeurs mais pas
seulement des représentants des
personnels et des syndicats des
inspecteurs des inspectrices du travail
et de la médecine du travail comme
autant de relais pour que les victimes
soient entendues et soutenues
juste quelques remarques pour conclure
qui sont en fait des points de vigilance
en lien avec les résultats qu'on a
présenté tout d'abord donc rappelons le
rôle essentiel des associations comme
l'association européenne sur les
violences faites aux femmes au travail à
la fois pour accompagner les victimes
qui souhaitent dénoncer des gens
sexuelles au travail mais aussi pour
développer une expertise spécifique sur
ces violences dont les enquêtes
statistiques même celles qui sont armées
de gros échantillons ne parviennent pas
complètement à saisir le détail des
actes ensuite mener une politique
spécifique de prévention et de formation
sur les violences sexistes au travail ne
peut pas incomber aux seuls employeurs
il faut sans doute armer d'autres
acteurs comme l'inspection du travail la
médecine du travail et syndicats où les
associations pour contribuer à cette
politique de prévention et enfin des
politiques ciblant les violences
sexistes ne peuvent sans doute pas faire
l'économie de l'amélioration plus
générale des conditions de travail et
d'emploi merci beaucoup de votre
attention
merci beaucoup mesdames pour cette
présentation à deux voix donc je vais
immédiatement passer la parole à Madame
Florence chaperte de la natte qui en
visio avec nous à vous madame oui
bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
et bien écoutez très bien bon n'hésitez
pas à ma connexion n'est pas très bonne
à me demander de couper ma caméra si
besoin pour l'instant c'est pas
nécessaire voilà je vous remercie donc
de nouveau de demander à la NACT
effectivement de partager son son retour
d'expérience à partir de cas
d'entreprises que nous avons sur ce
sujet de la prévention des violences
sexistes sexuelles au travail alors je
ne traiterai pas des violences
conjugales ou domestiques et de leur
impact sur le travail et je vous renvoie
effectivement
à ce sujet aux actions menées par la
Fédération nationale des centres
d'information des droits et des familles
puisqu'ils ont élaboré un très bon guide
sur le sujet voilà ils ont une
expérience que nous n'avons pas sur le
sujet alors mon intervention se
déroulera en quatre points
reprenons les éléments de votre
introduction les effets des violences
sexistes sexuelles au travail sur la
santé les causes et les facteurs de
risque dans le travail dont on déjà
parlé les deux sociologues précédemment
et puis les actions mises en passent par
les employeurs et enfin je terminerai
sur quelques recommandations
alors au niveau de effectivement
tout d'abord juste un préalable même si
le violon sexiste sexuelle sont de plus
en plus considérés par les employeurs
comme un vrai risque pour l'entreprise
avant tout un risque pour elle de
réputation donc un enjeu économique
c'est un sujet qui dans l'entreprise
fait encore l'objet aussi bien
individuellement et collectivement de
beaucoup beaucoup de déni et de tabou
les directions générales l'encadrement
le management
sous-estime à chaque fois que nous
allons en entreprise ce sujet sur le
terrain il n'y a pas de cashing ou bien
si il y a des cas c'est au sein des
équipes ou c'est en lien avec des
personnes extérieures des prestataires
des clients des fournisseurs et lors des
sessions de sensibilisation ce sujet
provoque souvent gêne et agressivité
notamment vis-à-vis des personnes qui
chez nous par exemple au de l'anake donc
l'agence nationale d'admiration des
conditions de travail chez les parodies
anime des sessions de formation alors
premier point les effets pour la santé
des femmes des violences sexistes et
sexuelles ce que nous avons pu constater
sur les victimes c'est qu'il y a
effectivement à la fois des impacts
psychologiques et physiques en termes de
culpabilité d'anxiété de dépression
d'insomnie migraines de stress
d'addiction tentatives de suicide
également des impacts sur le travail au
niveau des victimes perte de confiance
dans ses compétences isolement
absentéisme retard déconcentration avec
tous les risques de désinsertion de
mutation et de licenciement de rupture
conventionnelle éventuellement dans le
meilleur des cas
et puis des impacts bien sûr sur la vie
personnelle puisqu'il y a souvent s'il y
a un arrêt maladie trop long fin des
indemnités journalières au bout de trois
mois endettement difficultés avec
l'entourage qui se cumule rupture de vie
sociale il y a également des impacts sur
le collectif de travail sur les équipes
malaises des témoins ambiance de travail
dégradé tension clivage entre les
salariés
et puis bien sûr sur l'entreprise j'en
ai dit deux mots atteintes à l'image
avec le rôle des réseaux sociaux perte
de talent manque d'attractivité et puis
bien sûr risque de contentieux etc alors
le quart à ce sujet que je voulais vous
présenter c'est celui d'une agence
commerciale d'une entreprise
électronique internationale ce sont des
propos que je qui proviennent d'un
article de la revue des conditions de
travail numéro 13 aux éditions de La
nacte consacré aux questions d'égalité
un article écrit par Sophie Bardou qui
est une psychologue du travail dans un
service de prévention et de santé au
travail et de Sophie Morel qui est
chargé de mission dans une arraque dans
la région
alors dans ce cas donc cette agence
commerciale d'une entreprise
son siège est par chaque région à sa
direction régionale et la salarié
consacre concernée donc victime
travaille dans l'une des 20 agences
commerciales de la région dans cette
agence il y a cette salariés mais elle
est la seule femme assistante avec six
commerciaux sur le site de l'agence on
trouve également le bureau des
responsables des ressources humaines la
salarié le dépanne de temps en temps la
situation économique et florissante les
commerciaux sont très valorisées
l'ambiance interne est à la compétition
et à la surenchère
en fait c'est lors d'une visite médicale
donc auprès du médecin du travail après
plusieurs arrêts maladie que Madame V
s'effondre en pleurs elle explique
qu'elle ne dort plus n'a plus d'appétit
a perdu 10 kilos qu'elle souffre de
problèmes de mémoire de concentration
qu'elle sursaute fréquemment qu'elle
doute d'elle-même désormais de ses
compétences dans sa vie personnelle elle
est irritable néglige son apparence et
sa santé son couple est fragilisé elle
est totalement épuisée déclare un
diabète elle ne sait pas à qui en parler
malgré les menaces à peine déguiser du
RRH elle a tenté à plusieurs reprises
d'évoquer ça discrètement sa situation
au siège parisien mais personne ne
semble vouloir comprendre il lui
répondit nous avons pleinement confiance
en Monsieur B le RRH c'est un homme très
compétent sur qui l'on peut compter vous
êtes sûr que vous n'exagérez pas un peu
peut-être que vous êtes mal compris
essayez d'en parler avec lui
c'est un homme très ouvert avec un peu
de bonne volonté vous y arriverez elle
n'insiste pas car elle craint pour son
emploi sa carrière et conclut que cela
est vain le médecin du travail l'oriente
vers la psychologue du travail pour
qu'elle bénéficie d'un soutien moral et
qu'elle puisse y voir plus clair dans
cette situation sa situation
il est question de réfléchir aux
conditions de sa reprise du travail le
médecin du travail propose à la salarié
de se mettre en relation avec la
direction régionale mais elle devrait
faire pas craignant des représailles
finalement la perte des indemnités
journalières provoque un déclic et elle
prend conseil auprès de l'inspecteur du
travail d'un avocat qu'elle règle à ses
frais
la pression est mise sur l'entreprise
une enquête interne et menée
et finalement cette enquête conclut que
le RRH avait bien eu des propos des
agissements relevant du harcèlement
sexuel et du harcèlement le moral le RRH
et licencié de l'entreprise pour faute
grave les commerciaux reçoivent un
avertissement mais la salarié n'est pas
porté plainte au pénal elle nous dit
j'ai besoin de tourner la page et de
toute façon je ne crois pas en la
justice pour ce genre de choses le RRH
n'a donc pas été condamné la salarié
pouvait reprendre son travail mais un
syndrome d'évitement persistant se
traduit par une incapacité à revenir sur
le site et à faire face à l'équipe elle
négocia un départ lui permettant de se
reconstruire en tant que femme et en
tant que professionnel
voilà cela termine mon premier point sur
le deuxième point quels sont les
facteurs du risque qu'elle causent dans
l'environnement de travail
quand il y a des cas ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que les entreprises
gardent comme clé de lecture que les
violences c'est une question de
comportement inapproprié et quelles sont
la conséquence de relation
inter-individuelles l'auteur ne pense
qu'à ça la victime elle l'a bien cherché
ce qui est vrai mais ce qui n'est pas
suffisant et comme on dit les
sociologues les violences sexistes
sexuelles sont aussi la conséquence de
certains environnements de travail de
certaines organisations de travail de
certains fonctionnements collectifs
et cela a été confirmé par des études de
l'adresse et nos propres entiers de
terrain intervention de terrain nous
avons fait le constat que certains
facteurs organisationnels
exposent plus certains secteurs certains
métiers certains postes que d'autres aux
violences alors au niveau des
organisations comme cela était dit c'est
certains environnements de travail peu
mixtes après dominance masculine mais
aussi féminine comme la mode ou la
petite enfance vis-à-vis des hommes
c'est aussi certaines organisations de
travail très hiérarchisées comme à
l'hôpital ou très peu hiérarchisé comme
dans le monde du spectacle ou des
start-up
c'est aussi certains postes de travail
très dépendants ou très peu autonome ou
reconnu assistant assistante haute ou
hôtesses d'accueil et vous l'avez vu
avec l'audition de Gabriel Schultz qui
s'accompagne d'une répartition sexuée
sexiste des activités de travail avec
une dévalorisation des activités après
dominance féminine ce sont aussi comme
cela était dit des conditions d'emplois
les statuts précaires les stagiaires les
apprentis qui sont surexposés dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration de
la propreté de l'événementiel du
tourisme et au niveau des conditions de
travail ce sont certaines conditions de
travail le travail de nuit le soir le
travail isolé le travail sous pression
le travail avec des tenues ou une
scénographie sexuée et puis bien sûr les
métiers en relation avec le public les
usagers les clients les Béné ficiaires
et je pense au service à la personne
c'est d'ailleurs très significatif que
suite à la deuxième vague me too de 2021
le réseau anataracte a eu des demandes
de fédération sportive de secteurs de
l'événementiel du spectacle vivant et du
monde de l'enseignement supérieur
il y a ce sujet je ne peux recommander
le kit de prévention qui est à mon sens
le meilleur qui a été fait par en
collaboration avec le CHSCT de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma et qui
mentionne de manière très explicite et
qui met en parallèle d'une part les
facteurs de risque et d'autre part les
mesures de prévention à mettre en place
en situation de tournage de films par
exemple et il mentionne très
explicitement les situations de travail
isolé la précarité des contrats de
travail les rapports sociaux dégradés
entre collègues le travail de nuit les
déplacements le travail en relation avec
le public et puis plus précisément le
contexte de travail avec une grande
proximité
impliquant l'intimité il y a l'intimité
ou la nudité les situations d'emprise et
du pouvoir et bien sûr les situations
festives
situation de consommation de produits
désinhibants ou psychoactifs et si l'on
reprend mon cas précédent donc dans le
cadre de cette agence commerciale ce que
nous pouvons remarquer c'est que nous
retrouvons un certain nombre de facteurs
le premier est celui de manque de mixité
une seule femme effectivement avec cet
homme et puis c'est aussi la culture
viriliste commerciale de compétition
et c'est également concernant
l'organisation de l'activité de travail
cette dépendance de l'assistante
vis-à-vis des commerciaux qui ne
manquent pas de lui faire remarquer que
si elle a du travail ou un emploi c'est
grâce à eux
et puis c'est également cette culture
sexiste avec beaucoup de blagues à
connotation sexistes et sexuelle des
hommes qui se vendent de leur vie
sexuelle réelle ou fantasmée et qui
demande à cette
assistante beaucoup d'informations sur
sa propre vie sexuelle je vous passerai
l'ensemble des des verbatives et si on
rajoute à cela
le
des tentatives régulières de la part de
ces commerciaux et du RRH pour tenter
leurs chances pour une relation sexuelle
il se permet des effleurements
et n'obtenons pas ce qu'il veut le RRH
finalement intensifie la pression en la
harcelant moralement et l'on constate
souvent ce cumul de harcèlement moral et
du harcèlement sexuel avec refus des
congés horaires modifié modifier
l'empêchant d'aller à des rendez-vous
médicaux reprochent un Cesson
et puis le dernier facteur c'est
l'isolement sur le site avec les RRH
qu'on les commerciaux sont absents
celui-ci se permet de lui toucher les
fesses et les cuisses ce qui relève de
l'agression sexuelle quand j'allais à la
photocopieuse dit-elle il se collait à
moi et mettait ses mains dans mes
proches et je vais substinctement vous
présenter un deuxième cas un cas dans un
restaurant un cas en fait dans une unité
de travail qui pour le coup il mixte il
y a 15 salariés dit 10 femmes et 5
hommes 10 CDI et 5 contrats
d'apprentissage mais les postes
qualifiés à responsabilités sont celui
de chef de cuisine ou de chefs de rang
et sont pour les hommes et dans ce cas
là nous retrouvons un management très
paternaliste
sexiste et autoritaire de l'employeur
basé sur le divisé pour mieux régner
avec des réflexions du type
c'est encore en arrêt les filles vous
allez devoir vous sortir les doigts du
cul excusez-moi peut-être à ne pas
mettre dans la retranscription pour
faire son boulot ou bien dis donc les
deux là je ne veux plus vous voir
ensemble vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
raconter vos vies pour éplucher les
légumes si les mecs papotent comme des
gonzesses maintenant c'est encore cette
toujours cette culture de l'entreprise
avec ce chef dans la toute-puissance
reproduisant des schémas anciens
j'ai toujours vu ça en cuisine il faut
que ça tourne c'est comme à l'armée il y
a un chef et les autres s'écrase ce sont
bien sûr des conditions d'emplois avec
des femmes en situation de précarité car
ils sont tout apprentis ou mère isolés
et c'est le harcèlement par chantage ou
pression et rendu d'autant plus facile
c'est aussi ces conditions de travail
avec horaires décalés ce qui limite
d'ailleurs le nombre de témoins des
locaux inadaptés avec dans les cuisines
beaucoup de promiscuités des zones
favorisant les rapprochements et
légitimement les contacts et puis c'est
l'exigence de tenue féminine près du
corps pour les femmes qui sont serveuses
car c'est bon pour le commerce
voilà alors mon troisième point sera sur
les mesures mises en place pour prévenir
les employeurs
même si les entreprises considèrent ce
sujet comme l'ont dit les sociologues
comme un sujet de prévention et non pas
un sujet égalité d'ailleurs prévention
en lien avec leur responsabilité en
matière de moyens et du résultat en
matière de santé psychique et mentale
les entreprises en fait ne se
préoccupent des violences sexistes et
sexuelles qu'à l'occasion soit du
traitement d'une alerte ou d'un
signalement du harcèlement sexuel par
exemple ou d'agressions sexuelle mais là
on agit après c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prévention tertiaire ou bien à
l'occasion de sensibilisation ou de
formation du personnel ce qu'on appelle
la prévention secondaire on forme pour
apprendre à reconnaître les situations à
risque ou signaler
mais les entreprises remontent très
rarement à ce qu'on appelle de la
prévention primaire pour limiter les
facteurs du risque au niveau des
conditions de travail ou des situations
inégalitaires entre les hommes
si je reprends le premier point
concernant la prévention tertiaire le
traitement d'une alerte ou d'un
signalement ce que l'on constate dans
les entreprises c'est qu'elle traite les
situations aujourd'hui au cas par cas
mais cela comporte beaucoup de limites
d'abord il y a une sous-décration énorme
des plaintes une sous-déclaration
car par crainte de représailles les
victimes n'osent pas dénoncer en interne
et les entreprises sont très réticentes
à externaliser le recueil des plaintes
par le biais de numéro dédié ou de
services extérieur ce que nous leur
recommandons
s'il y a dénonciation l'enquête là aussi
est menée trop souvent en interne or
c'est très compliqué de mettre en cause
un collègue encore plus un supérieur et
archique un directeur ou une directrice
et c'est très difficile aussi de garder
la confidentialité or nous recommandons
aussi que l'enquête soit réalisée en
externe le troisième point très
compliqué c'est l'impunité des auteurs
qui fait que les victimes se disent à
quoi bon c'est ce qu'on a vu dans le cas
d'un reste du restaurant justement où
finalement le chef cuisinier inculpé
sera
finalement aura 10 jours de suspension
de de travail mais finalement cela ne
l'empêche pas de revenir dans le
restaurant
et finalement c'est l'apprenti qui est
parti et qui n'a pas pu reprendre le
travail il y a réellement un point dur
sur cette question d'impunité car les
entreprises n'osent pas m'y annoncer ni
inscrire dans leurs accords égalité
qu'elles vont sanctionner et du coup on
se retrouve encore trop dans des
situations où ce sont les victimes qu'on
change de poste qu'on change de site ou
qui s'octo excluent en quittant
l'entreprise il s'est d'ailleurs le
cabinet emprunt humaine qui a analysé
quatre cas du harcèlement sexuel en
association avec un laboratoire de
recherche de l'Université de Grenoble
Alpes c'est aussi d'ailleurs l'objet
d'un article de la revue des conditions
de travail numéro 13 de la nake où les
auteurs définissent très bien ce qu'est
un climat organisationnel sexiste avec
l'aide de trois critères
1 la banalisation des agissements
faisons sexistes ou sexuel faisons
partie du métier et d'ailleurs le chef
cuisinier inculpé dans ce restaurant
explique très bien la prend conscience
de ses actes mais il dit moi-même en
tant qu'apprenti homme j'ai été victime
de tous ces actes quand j'étais dans mon
apprentissage je croyais que cela
faisait partie du travail et du métier
deuxième point c'est ce sentiment
d'impunité qui est associé d'ailleurs à
une inversion de la culpabilité au
niveau de la victime puisque le les
personnes arrivent à montrer à la
victime que c'est finalement elle qui
est coupable d'avoir mis mini-jupe
d'avoir provoqué etc et le troisième
point très marquant également que
mentionne ces auteurs c'est le manque de
recadrage de la hiérarchie un la
hiérarchie ne voit pas ne sait pas et de
elle ne sait pas comment réagir et elle
ne réagit pas
alors en matière c'était le point sur la
prévention tertiaire je vais aller plus
rapidement sur la prévention secondaire
qui concerne les sensibilisations ou la
formation du personnel il nous en avons
réalisé un certain nombre quand comme de
plus en plus de consultants comme le
réseau des CIDFF comme la VFT dont on
parlait les sociologues en fait
sensibiliser former c'est bien mais
c'est insuffisant d'abord la majorité
des salariés n'ont pas encore bénéficié
en France même si c'est une obligation
de l'employeur
les salariés en France ne distinguent
pas toujours pas
ne distingue toujours pas les situations
non sexistes du harcèlement sexuel du
harcèle du harcèlement sexuel des
agressions sexuelles et du viol même
s'il y a une des nuances à faire selon
l'âge or l'objectif est quand même de
former des gens capables de témoigner
même si comme l’ont dit les sociologues
ils ne font pas leur faire reposer toute
l'entière responsabilité mais c'est un
chercheur Benoît Dardenne qui en 2021
souligne la nécessité d'être sensibilisé
aux violences pour pouvoir déceler une
situation de harcèlement sexuel et donc
décidé d'intervenir ou non
mais les modules en ligne qui sont très
souvent proposés notamment pour les
managers ne permet pas de discuter or
pour pouvoir sensibiliser il faut
pouvoir discuter de ce sujet en intrant
entreprise il faut pouvoir lever le
tabou débattre des limites que les
équipes se donnent notamment en matière
de sexisme ordinaire de blagues et c'est
pour cela que nous nous avons par
exemple à un acte produit un jeu sexisme
sans façon qui permet en trois quarts
d'heure de distinguer six niveaux de
sexisme quand je parle de sexisme cela
va du sexisme bienveillant jusqu'au viol
le contenu des formations de
sensibilisation animée par les
consultants portent de notre point de
vue aujourd'hui des approches beaucoup
trop comportementales il se permettent
par exemple de donner des conseils aux
femmes pour ne pas porter de mini-jupe
mais il est vrai que nous avons pu
constater aussi des actions qui sont
tout à fait intéressants dans un certain
nombre
d'entreprises je pense par exemple à ce
bailleur social qui a tout d'abord formé
les membres du CODIR et l'argile puis
l'ensemble des comités de management qui
a réalisé également une campagne
d'affichage un peu choc pour rendre le
sujet visible sur risques et pour
interpeller
c'est également il a mis en place ce
bailleur social des petits groupes pour
libérer la parole et plus de 250
collaborateurs ont pu participer à des
actions de sensibilisation au VST ils
ont enfin réalisé une note de service
une newsletter en mentionnant les
référents les instances représentatives
le service RH le médecin du travail le
psychologue du travail avec toutes les
coordonnées
alors sur le troisième point
avant que je ne compte plus sur la
prévention primaire les entreprises
mettent très rarement en place des
démarches collectives et
organisationnelles qui associe le sieste
elles en restent toujours à une approche
individuelle et comportement
comportemental au lieu d'en faire un
sujet collectif qui implique donc la
direction des représentants du personnel
les encadrants les références yse et RH
sont de très bons atouts mais leur
mission ne reste pas définie leur rôle
reste très fragile il manque de temps il
manque de moyens
et comme l'on dit les sociologues les
entreprises abordent de très peu ce
sujet avec une approche systémique et
c'est un peu comme le même sujet que les
abus sexuels dans le rapport de la
science les entreprises très peu les cas
en aval pour en tirer des conséquences
pour l'amont sur les postes ou les
situations de travail à risque et au
final ce que l'on constate c'est qu'il
subsiste un très grand décalage entre
les intentions les engagements par
exemple la tolérance zéro la sanction
des auteurs et les actions menées et
finalement les actions ponctuelles
aujourd'hui ne produisent pas les
résultats escomptés il ne suffisent pas
pour considérer triste que de violence
comme sexistes et sexuelles comme un
véritable risque professionnel et
engager les actions de prévention
nécessaire mais à noter pour exemple
toujours que l'on retrouve dans la revue
des conditions de travail de la nacte
que ce bailleur social a inscrit le
risque de violence sexiste et sexuelle
dans le document unique d'évaluation des
risques à modifier son règlement
intérieur notamment sur le plan des
sanctions et a fait notamment une
information lors de l'accueil des
nouveaux embauchés je vais prendre
encore quelques minutes pour conclure
sous forme de recommandation
effectivement suite à tous ces constats
et ces difficultés la nacte considère
comme indispensable au-delà de la
sensibilisation et du traitement
individuel des cas d'apporter aux
entreprises
dirigeants représentant du personnel
référent CSE référent RH en priorité des
capacités d'action au niveau de
l'organisation et au niveau collectif
nous mettons en avant quatre
recommandations
la première recommandation c'est qu'il y
a nécessité de renforcer l'articulation
du système de prévention aux trois
niveaux cette fameuse prévention
tertiaire pour qualifier l'effet dans
les situations avérées accompagner les
victimes sanctionner les auteurs en
mobilisant les entreprises pour qu'elles
fassent plus à peine aux ressources
externes nous appuies externes pour
traiter les situations
et pour mener les enquêtes
en prévention secondaire effectivement
que soit systématisé et rendu
obligatoire les formations
sensibilisation de longue des salariés
mais de manière spécifique des managers
des dirigeants et en prévention primaire
j'y reviendrai la deuxième
recommandation c'est d'associer
l'ensemble des acteurs et pour cela de
mieux définir les rôles émissions des
référentiel se RH de leur donner plus de
moyens
et moyen de travail en lien avec les
directs présentant du personnel manager
et salarié c'est d'ailleurs l'objet du
projet de l'appel approché violon c'est
sexiste et sexuelle du ministère chargé
de l'égalité dont la nacte et L'Oréal
comme d'autres projets mais c'est aussi
d'associer en externe les acteurs de la
santé au travail et dans le cadre du
Plan Santé au Travail numéro 4 ce sont
les services de prévention et de santé
au travail qui sont ciblés sur ce sujet
de la prévention des violences mais
c'est aussi les carsats les inspections
du travail et puis bien sûr les
associations de protection des victimes
ou les CIDFF la VHT les conseils
juridiques
et puis il s'agit en troisième
recommandation que l'entreprise
communique sur l'ensemble des actions
mises en oeuvre les chercheurs
chercheurs ont très bien mis en évidence
des salariés ayant connaissance des
politiques organisationnels en matière
de prévention adoptent beaucoup plus
facilement des stratégies qu'on appelle
de faire face active et donc vont
signaler témoigner lorsque les travail
les milieux de travail ne montrent pas
leurs implications les salariés sont
moins inclinés enclins à témoigner et
puis le dernier point c'est pour nous en
tant qu'anac d'insister sur la
prévention primaire non pas pour réduire
à zéro le risque de violences sexistes
et sexuelles comme pour les risques
psychosociaux le risque zéro n'existe
pas
mais de limiter du réduire les facteurs
du risque et cela passe par la mise en
place de 5 types d'action
réaliser un diagnostic des facteurs de
risque organisationnel suivant les
différents points que nous avons
mentionnés
le type de management les conditions
d'emploi et de précarité les conditions
de travail
deuxième point intégrer bien sûr le
risque de violence sexy sexuelle dans le
document unique d'évaluation des risques
c'est d'ailleurs un levier important sur
lequel on peut mobiliser les entreprises
car s'il y a un cas de harcèlement
sexuel dans leur entreprise ou
l'agression
elles peuvent être mises en défaut et
payer des indemnités si elles n'ont pas
intégré sur le risque on leur document
unique mais d'une manière générale on le
sait et cela fait l'objet d'une audition
précédente que les risques
professionnels auxquels sont exposées
les femmes sont sous-estimées
quatrième point réaliser un diagnostic
des ressources en prévention primaire
secondaire tertiaire et puis c'est
construire des outils collectifs de
prévention en lien avec le CSE ou la
Commission ssct et cela se traduit par
des mesures organiques
intégration et tutorat des nouveaux et
particulièrement des personnes en statut
précaire
et je le redis les stagiaires les jeunes
les personnes apprenties sont les plus
exposées c'est aussi l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et d'emplois et là
je parle de choses très basiques des
vestiaires les toilettes séparées hommes
femmes des cloisons et des portes
vitrées à mi-hauteur pour que les papes
les personnes ne se retrouvent pas
isolées dans des bureaux c'est
l'éclairage des couloirs c'est les
conditions de trajet domicile travail
quand il y a retour la nuit c'est une
prescription des tenues et des
scénographies de travail à connotation
sexuelle c'est un travail sur la
composition mixte des équipes ne pas
avoir une femme ou un homme seul dans
une équipe mono-saxe c'est une
répartition homme femme équilibrée des
activités limitant la division sexuée du
travail cela passe aussi par la
valorisation des activités des postes
après dominance féminine
et puis c'est la mise en place d'espace
de discussion dans les collectifs de
travail pour que par exemple les
assistantes comme nous l'avons trop
souvent rencontrés ne se retrouvent pas
isolé et n'osent pas parler des avances
sexuelles dont elles sont l'objet et le
dernier point c'est de mettre en place
une politique égalitée professionnelle
qui réduisent effectivement les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes et qui consacrent dans les
accords ou plan d'entreprise un volet
dédié à la prévention des violences
sexistes et sexuelles voilà j'ai terminé
beaucoup j'étais un petit peu longue
merci beaucoup madame
chaperte donc je vais immédiatement
passer la parole à Madame Rafael manière
de la CGT Merci à VOUS bonjour vous
m'entendez bien
merci pour cette invitation évidemment
la première chose qu'on se dit c'est que
ce sujet là des violences sexistes
sexuelles sur les femmes au travail
c'est un sujet à part entière
aurait pu être traité dans une saisie à
part alors peut-être que vos prochains
travaux pourront partir sur cette
dimension unique parce que si toutes les
femmes ne vont pas subir des TMS dans
leur parcours professionnel on sait que
quasiment toute vont subir du sexisme et
beaucoup d'entre elles vont subir des
violences sexuelles dans leur parcours
professionnel entre harcèlement sexuel
agression et viol et que du coup on peut
le dire comme ça en fait les femmes au
travail elles sont finalement dans des
lieux où le danger règne et le danger
existe et quand on parle de violences
systémique c'est de ça dont on parle les
chiffres donc moi je leur dis pas on les
connaît ils ont été redis ils sont
insuffisants mais ils indiquent
l'ampleur du phénomène face auquel nous
sommes
toutes les femmes sont concernées sur
sur les violences sexistes et sexuelles
jeunes vieilles ca ouvrière stagiaire
alternante intérimaire quelle que soit
leur statut elles vont subir dans leur
parcours professionnel à un moment donné
elles vont se retrouver dans une
situation même ponctuelle ou les
relations vont être déséquilibrées entre
elles et un collègue ou des collègues ou
avec un chef ou avec des clients ou bien
entendu aussi avec des conjoints ou des
relations ponctuelles amoureuses qui
seront salariés dans le même endroit
qu'elle c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
qui est grave parce que c'est une
atteinte à la dignité des femmes
quelles sont ces violences au cœur du
processus de domination et que parler
d'égalité professionnelle et salariale
sans éradiquer en amont les violences
sexistes et sexuelles c'est un non sens
puisque la condition à la mise en place
de cette égalité même c'est de pouvoir
parler de ces violences
sexistes et sexuelles elles sont graves
aussi parce qu'elles remettent en cause
le droit fondamental des femmes à
travailler quel est leur place au
travail dans ces situations là comment
elles gardent leur place au travail on
sait qu'elle pour la majorité d'elle
elles vont pas garder leur place au
travail elles sont remises en cause dans
ce droit là c'est une remise en cause de
leur autonomie et de leur indépendance
financière évidemment et puis c'est
grave parce que les violences elles ont
un impact je reviens pas dessus sur
la capacité des femmes à s'investir au
travail avec un manque d'estime de soi
qui va se prononcer une perte de
confiance de la culpabilité de la honte
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'ai laissé
dire ça j'ai laissé faire ça une fois
deux fois et après ben c'est un peu tard
j'aurais dû réagir avant
alors j'avais envie de poser la question
de on en est au travail depuis MiTo
notamment puisque quand même cette ce
mouvement moment exceptionnel de
conscientisation des violences
masculines qui ont lieu au travail
[Musique]
et il manque une volonté politique forte
de changement qui suppose de bousculer
le patronat les employeurs et les
administrations publiques il faut il
faut discuter en fait or pour l'instant
on assiste en tout cas notre sens à des
postures de repli et de
ça les embête les violences arrivent
sous leurs yeux au travail mais qu'il
fallait les régler
[Musique]
quand là il a tenté elle a dit non il va
inverser il va il va continuer la mise
en place de cette relation de domination
en mettant en cause ses compétences au
travail en mettant un système en place
qui va la décrédibiliser et là ça peut
être un moment pour les femmes où ça
c'est pas supportable elles vont
supporter des choses en amont laisser
écouler mais attaquer leur travail ça
s'est pas supportable et ça peut être
dans ces moments là aussi où elles vont
dire et dénoncer ce qui se passe pour
elle bah ces situations là elles sont
pas si parce qu'en fait il faut
débusquer le sexisme dans les dossiers
de harcèlement moral à caractère sexiste
voilà c'est pas simple mais c'est hyper
intéressant j'allais dire à faire en
fait parce que ça a du sens on comprend
pourquoi il se passe ce phénomène pour
elle de
décrédibilisation sur son travail alors
qu'elle travaille bien mais finalement
c'est parce qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose en amont
alors il y a un autre angle mort c'est
les situations de violence conjugales
les femmes au travail
on a on a peu de chiffres enfin moi j'en
connais pas avec ces trois dimensions
possibles donc cette très brillant la
première et c'est le scénario le plus
simple entre guillemets c'est celui où
ce sont des couples il y a beaucoup de
couples au travail qui se font et qui se
défont donc ces situations de couple
avec les deux salariés sur le même
travail
l'autre scénario c'est elles vont subir
des violences de couple elle elles sont
salariés monsieur et ailleurs mais les
femmes victimes de féminicides sont des
pour beaucoup des femmes salariées et
donc qu'est-ce qu'on sait d'elle de leur
situation au travail on en sait rien
enfin
ça sera intéressant de savoir ces femmes
qui qui sont mortes assassinées elles
étaient salariées dans quel lieu de
travail est-ce qu'il y avait une alerte
qui avait pu être posée pourquoi le lieu
de travail n'était pas un ressource un
lieu de ressources pour elle finalement
et comment on construit ce lieu de
ressources pour elle au travail c'est ça
la question qui est posée la troisième
possibilité sur les violences de couple
c'est très prégnant aussi ben c'est le
fait qu'il y ait des relations
ponctuelles dans les lieux même lieu de
travail entre les femmes et les hommes
et là aussi nous on a des scénarios
comme ça ou les représailles et le
harcèlement se met en place quand la
relation cesse mais ils sont c'est un
couple non cohabitant mais pourtant on
peut parler de violence de couple même
si ils vivent pas ensemble donc tous ces
scénarios là se présentent
au délégué du personnel aux salariés
évidemment aux employeurs
avec nous cette impression qu'on
retrouve dans ce que vous disiez madame
chaper c'est la patate chaude pour les
employeurs quand il y a quand il y a une
alerte qui est posée je voulais vous
donner à voir parce que je suis
oui je suis note aussi
je travaille en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
à la vente et la SNCF donc à un accord
égalité pro avec un volet violent et
sexiste sexiste et sexuel et notamment
il y a une bonne pratique qui est
intéressante
ils ont un baromètre Ifop tous les ans
donc l'Ifop ça fait quatre ans travail
sur un échantillon à peu près de 2000
personnes 1025 femmes 992 hommes c'est à
ma connaissance la seule grande
entreprise à faire un travail comme ça
de visibilité sur les violences sexistes
et sexuelles pour la première année
l'année dernière elle a intégré la
dimension violence sexuelle sur notre
demande et donc ça donne sur il y a deux
il y a la fois la perception du sexisme
le sexisme et la perception des
violences sexistes et sexuelles quelques
chiffres à partager avec vous parce que
dans cette bonne pratique ça permet
quand même de conscientiser moi j'ai des
collègues quand on leur a donné les
chiffres ils ont un petit peu cogité
dans leur tête parce que évidemment ils
ont du mal à se dire quand ils ont des
réflexions ils ont du mal à se dire
qu'ils sont des gros machos que ça c'est
du harcèlement ou que s'il touche à cet
endroit là c'est une agression ils
savent pas et je ne le dis pas pour les
dédouaner mais on est vraiment dans
cette nécessité de donner à voir pour
faire grandir tout le monde sur ce qui
se passe sur le sexisme à la SNCF il y a
47% de femmes qui se disent victimes de
sexisme c'est c'est pas beaucoup comme
comme chiffre presque on pourrait dire
regarder les chiffres qu'on peut
connaître ça montre ça monte chez les
contrôleuses oui c'est beaucoup mais
quand on c'est beaucoup mais en même
temps je suis sûr qu'il y en a plus que
47%
des contrôles ça monte à 67% et sur les
violences sexistes alors sexuelles donc
harcèlement sexuel l'agression sexuelle
viol et on n'a pas le détail c'est 21%
des femmes à la SNCF et ça monte à 39%
pour les contrôlesuses donc ça permet à
l'employeur de se dire qu'il faut mettre
un plan de prévention particuliers sur
ce personnel normalement après c'est la
problématique de la mise en oeuvre des
plans de prévention puisque ça c'est
vraiment problématique dans tous les
lieux de travail et ce qui était
intéressant aussi dans ce baromètre
c'est le fait que les femmes se disent
elles sont comme par hasard elles sont
plus témoins que les hommes et ça c'est
important parce que quand on a des
enquêtes les témoins directs elles sont
rares par contre les témoins indirects
il y en a souvent et donc voilà on
observe finalement les femmes seraient
en tout cas dans ce baromètre plus
témoin peut-être avec un œil plus
aguerri sur ce qui se passe autour
d'elle dans les relations de travail
alors ce qui était intéressant c'est que
elles sont de plus en plus à dénoncer ce
qui se passe pour elle au travail même
si
pour beaucoup elle ne disent rien et sur
la dimension violence conjugale bah là
aussi grande invisible ça a pas été pris
en compte dans le baromètre donc il y a
un gros travail à faire sur sur cette
dimension là il y a du désavancées quand
même depuis 2017 avec notamment 2018 la
mise en place des référentes et référent
harcèlement sexuels et agissant sexiste
dans les boîtes de plus de 250 c'est un
dispositif insuffisant mais c'est un
début qui qui doit permettre bon je
reviendrai après sur les préco il dans
les autres avancées il y a une
obligation de négocier dans les branches
une obligation de traiter les vs dans
les documents uniques d'évaluation des
risques professionnels et ça ça c'est
pas fait pourtant ça c'est indispensable
pour établir qu'ils sont les facteurs de
risque dans tous les lieux de travail
il y a aussi
autre chose intéressante donc accord
égalité décliné dans les trois versants
de la fonction publique avec la création
donc des référents aussi violence
sexistes et sexuelles et puis ben on a
depuis 2019 la première loi mondiale
avec leït la convention 206 donc ça
c'est des c'est des tremplins pour aller
plus loin et il faut aller plus loin
nous ce qu'on observe dans les lieux de
travail c'est qu'il y a un besoin auprès
des employeurs toujours de comme pour
eux c'est la patate chaude on a besoin
de leur réexpliquer et d'expliquer aux
collègues aussi
il faut politiser le débat des violences
sexistes et sexuelles de travail de
rappeler que c'est pas une fatalité que
c'est un combat politique et qu'elle et
qu'elle ne résulte pas de problème
individuels on pointe évidemment la
responsabilité des employeurs qui est
énorme puisque ils ont la triple
obligation de prévention de protéger les
victimes de sanctions des agresseurs et
sur les trois dimensions on a beaucoup
de points de vigilance que je vais vous
citer après et puis en bataille beaucoup
en interne pour réexpliquer que ces
situations de violence on peut pas les
réduire à une vision de conflit
interpersonnel c'est pas un problème de
Monsieur et Madame qui s'entendent pas
il s'est passé autre chose à un moment
donné il y a une situation de domination
qui s'est mis en place une relation
déséquilibrée et c'est celle là qu'il
faut identifier pour permettre aux
ampleurs de comprendre que
les choses peuvent être remises à
l'endroit
plutôt que de parler de catégorie
sociale professionnelle
plus ciblées ou de lieu de travail je
pense c'est plus intéressant de
réfléchir aux situations vulnérabilité
que subissent tout le monde subit des
situations de vulnérabilité dans sa vie
et donc c'est assez moment là qui peut
se passer quelque chose dans les lieux
de travail donc ces situations de
vulnérabilité et puis
toujours cette nécessité d'identifier
les facteurs de risque pour pouvoir
anticiper les problèmes en fait les
prévenir
et sur le je pense que ça ce qui serait
intéressant aussi c'est de réfléchir à
quels sont les lieux de travail
finalement où les femmes ont pu ont été
le plus en capacité de rester
on est plus sur une problématique de
statut
être alternante stagiaire intérimaire en
CDD sa fragilise les femmes qui vont
vivre des situations de violence alors
que si elles sont si relève de de
fonctions de la fonction publique alors
ou de d'employeurs publics et qui a
encore une garantie de l'emploi c'est
pour elle le meilleur moyen de sortir au
mieux de ces situations de violence qui
vont pour certaines quand même les
détruites les détruire pendant pendant
quelques mois nous dans les points de
vigilance il y avait donc trois trois
registres sur la prévention le chiffre
qu'on a c'est 80% des entreprises qui
n'ont pas de plan de prévention donc là
on a un gros souci parce que les femmes
ne parlent pas 70% des femmes ne parle
pas donc comment mettre en place des
dispositifs et une communication la
formation dans les lieux de travail pour
qu'elle s'autorise à parler qu'elle
dépasse justement
ce sentiment de honte à une culpabilité
qui va les les
tenir
comment les dispositifs dispositifs
pourraient être mis en place de
signalement pour donner confiance
justement si les procédures sont données
à avoir aux salariés quand elles sont
victimes de violence elles auront
peut-être plus la confiance pour poser
l'alerte que si elle ne savent pas ce
qui se passe quand elle parle et donc ça
ce sont des dispositifs à gagner
enfin qui devrait être mis en place dans
dans la fonction publique et au niveau
du privé on est en train de d'en gagner
certains dans certains accords égalité
pro
et c'est intéressant mais c'est du
Global pour que tout marche
[Musique]
la deuxième chose c'est sur la prise en
charge des femmes victimes bah là c'est
problématique c'est c'est la dimension
qu'il faut travailler de façon urgente
à l'avenir puisque
si dans la fonction publique il y a
quand même la protection fonctionnelle
qui existe qui pourrait être un levier
un vrai levier de protection pour les
femmes ce qu'on observe malheureusement
c'est que quand elle veulent le
mobiliser sur les situations de
violences sexistes sexuelles les
employeurs publics ne leur autorisent
pas cela donc elles sont obligées
d'aller alors là pour celles qui vont
ils sont obligés d'aller au tribunal
administratif pour faire reconnaître ce
droit à la protection fonctionnelle qui
est hyper important parce que
parce que c'est l'autorisation à
une aide financière si elle décide
d'aller en justice par l'employeur mais
c'est aussi une aide financière pour les
soins
voilà la prise en charge psychologique
dont elles vont avoir besoin pour
continuer leur chemin et revenir au
travail et toute la bataille parce que
c'est une bataille quand on dénonce des
violences dans les lieux de travail
c'est une bataille qui s'engage avec
avec parfois l'employeur avec les
collègues
voilà la médecine du travail n'est pas
toujours disponible l'inspection du
travail c'est compliqué aussi donc il y
a un sentiment d'isolement qui est très
fort et qui est difficile donc
au niveau de des employeurs publics ça
devrait être exemplaire voilà on devrait
avoir déjà des procédures il y a des il
y a des circulaires il y a des accords
égalité pro qui devraient engager et
permettre une exemplarité des
comportements des employeurs publics et
malheureusement c'est pas ce qu'on
observe les femmes dans les
administrations publiques sont aussi
maltraités qu'ailleurs
mais peut-être juste sur la fin c'est
qu'elles vont moins sortir vite de
l'emploi que celle qui ce qui n'ont pas
cette protection de l'emploi mais donc
c'est pas rien c'est très important mais
pour dire qu'il y a du travail sur
l'amont
il y a des droits nouveaux à conquérir
il y a bon il y a des une obligation de
sécurité pour l'employeur de formation
de prévention il y a aussi des nouveaux
droits et nous comme au Canada ou en
Nouvelle-Zélande qui a mis en place des
dispositifs de 10 jours de congés
supplémentaires pour les femmes victimes
du violence conjugales c'est à dire
qu'avec ces 10 jours les employeurs
leur permettent de faire leur démarche
auprès auprès du juge auprès de la
police auprès de l'assistante sociale
auprès donc c'est dix jours en plus qui
existent et qui sont maintenant
officiels dans ces deux pays
nous aussi on a besoin de droit nouveau
pour les femmes qui en ont pas que
celles qui subissent des violences
conjugales pour toutes celles qui
subissent les violences sexistes et
sexuelles de travail
parce qu'elles ont besoin de temps en
fait alors 10 jours ça peut paraître pas
beaucoup beaucoup pour certaines en tout
cas chaque situation est en différente
ça sera intéressant de voir une
flexibilité sur un droit nouveau à avoir
des jours pour s'occuper de soi pour
qu'elle puisse garder son emploi et
et prendre soin d'elle parce que le
problème c'est que les personnes qui
sont victimes de violence sexuelles
c'est une effraction psychique et donc
derrière ça les choses ne vont pas
devenir normal il y a besoin d'un temps
il y a la mémoire traumatique elles vont
avoir des flashs parfois quand l'enquête
est lancée
l'enquête s'est censé durer quelques
mois mais elle elle vont avoir des
flashs qui vont revenir encore des mois
et des mois après de ressasser ce qui a
pu se passer dans un lieu de travail qui
peut durer parfois des années ça peut
aussi être court tous les scénarios sont
possibles mais
l'enquête quand elle est quand elle
quand elle a lieu l'employeur il attend
de la salarié qu'une fois que l'enquête
est faite que la sanction est posée
qu'elle revienne et que tout va bien et
on en parle plus mais ça se passe pas
comme ça
elle est victime de violence elle a
besoin de temps pour se reconstruire et
donc derrière on va tourner on peut
tourner en rond dans certaines
situations puisque pour savoir qu'elle
va être elle dans quelle place elles
veulent elles veulent être un nouveau
travail peut-être qu'elles auront besoin
d'être dans un autre atelier un autre
espace un autre lieu de travail donc
pour cette mutation géographique qui
pourrait être aussi un nouveau droit
pour qu'elle le réfléchisse
tranquillement faut d'abord qu'elles
aiment bien il faut d'abord qu'elle se
soit occupées de leur santé psychique et
donc ça ça demande du temps mais souvent
dans les lieux de travail il y a pas le
temps en fait on demande tu reviens là
il faut réfléchir tout de suite donc il
y a cette confrontation de de
temporalité je m'exprime pas bien je
suis désolé qui
qui ça frotte ça va pas il y a une
temporalité qu'il faut prendre en compte
pour pour les victimes et ça dans les
lieux de travail avec les employeurs
c'est c'est pas acquis puisque toute
façon globalement ils sont pas formés
on a des points de vigilance aussi par
rapport aux procédures d'enquête alors
pourtant le code du travail est clair et
la boîte à outils est assez simple
puisque les définitions
ne demandent pas aux employeurs de
vérifier l'intention de l'agresseur de
nuire les employeurs ils ont pas à
vérifier ça ça c'est du pénal les
employeurs ils ont à vérifier nul ne
doit subir donc ils ont juste à vérifier
entre guillemets la situation de travail
a été malmenée à un moment donné avec
une relation déséquilibrée et voir de
domination ça c'est le faisceau d'indice
c'est le récit de la victime c'est la
prise en compte des témoins directs et
indirects qui permet d'établir si c'est
passé quelque chose de normal ou pas au
travail et si l'enquête dit qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose d'anormal au travail
il y a pas besoin de démontrer qu'il
avait conscience de ce qu'il faisait
même si bien souvent les agresseurs
savent bien ce qu'ils font quand même
mais là il y a pas besoin de chercher
cette intentionnalité de la prouver
qu'en plus dans les violences sexuelles
ils reconnaissent tous en continuant
leurs phrases par mais elle était
d'accord donc
ça va être compliqué de démontrer qu'il
y avait une intention de nuire mais
l'employeur lui c'est simple la boîte à
outils et les carrés ils doivent agir
dès qu'il y a cette ce questionnement
sur la relation qui n'a pas été une
relation de travail et donc
pourtant nous ce qu'on observe c'est
beaucoup de tentations
d'agir tant qu'il y a pas de plainte les
ampleurs souvent ne veulent pas agir
alors qu'il y a pas d'obligation pour
les victimes d'aller au pénal donc il y
a cette vigilance là que nous on a il y
a la vigilance aussi par rapport aux
enquêtes c'est à dire comme le disait
madame chaper nous aussi on observe que
les employeurs
n'aime pas que les enquêtes soient
faites par les délégués du personnel via
la cssct si un droit d'alerte ou une
déclaration d'accident du travail c'est
une possibilité pour le CS via la cssct
d'enquêter donc d'avoir une enquête
conjointe ce qui nous semble nous
important parce que ça permet
l'impartialité et ça permet aussi donc
pour le coup nous on préconise pas que
les entreprises
donnent les enquêtes à l'externe auprès
des cabinets qui et en ce moment il y a
bout des cabinets qui se mettent en
place et
c'est cher de dire toutes les
entreprises elles auront pas 10000 euros
à donner un cabinet pour enquêter
pendant deux mois donc la question se
pose de savoir faire le travail en
interne donc comment on se faire on se
forme et les enquêtes conjointes via la
CSCT c'est vraiment un moment de
formation c'est peut-être bête de le
dire comme ça mais c'est comme ça on va
les former avant mais quand il y a une
enquête c'est aussi un moment réfléchit
ensemble on écoute la victime les
témoins le mise en cause on va entendre
le mise en cause et c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on grandit et qu'on et qui a de la
pédagogie qui se met en place en fait
dans le lieu de travail parce que le but
c'est de détailler le sujet il est trop
souvent mis sous le sous le tabi le
tapis avec des employeurs ne sachant pas
par quel bout commencer donc ils ont
besoin d'accompagnement voilà il faut
aussi des structures qui sachent les
accompagner mais il faut pas enlever la
responsabilité
enfin évidemment pas aux employeurs mais
c'est bien d'emmener les représentants
du personnel aussi dans ses capacités
d'enquêtes parce que d'abord en plus
c'est eux souvent qui font les droits
d'alerte on a observé nous une
difficulté à qualifier les employeurs
ils veulent pas qualifier or si on
qualifie pas on donne pas on rend pas
visible la nature des violences qui ont
eu lieu et nous on s'est rendu compte
que les victimes souvent ne savent pas
faire la différence entre harcèlement
sexuel et une agression sexuelle donc il
faut qualifier ce qui s'est passé
on n'a pas besoin d'être juges pour dire
que toucher les hanches les épaules et
le ventes ça relève du harcèlement
sexuel ce sont des attouchements mais
les cuisses et les fesses et les seins
et les seins c'est une agression
sexuelle donc il y a besoin de toujours
dans cette
en fait nécessité de pédagogie et de
formation mais qui est en continu
évidemment il doit y avoir la prévention
en amont tout ce que disait madame
chaper à toutes les strates mais quand
il y a des dossiers il y a aussi dans le
continuum de la vie d'un collectif de
travail en fait
quand il y a un signalement ça devrait
servir à ce que tout le monde sorte plus
grand de ce qui s'est passé plutôt que
de se retrouver avec des collectifs de
travail qui vont être clivés ou derrière
la reprise du travail va être très
compliquée pour la victime parce que les
choses ne vont pas être dites et
travailler avec elle
et donc elle elle va subir la double
peine d'avoir subi à la fois des
violences et de ne pas retrouver sa
place au travail
voilà sur les enquêtes la mise à pied
conservatoire du mise en cause on a
remarqué que c'était aussi difficile
c'est à dire c'est pris comme une
sanction alors que ça ne l'est pas c'est
un moment au contraire ça permet de
lever la pression sur un lieu de travail
le la personne mise en cause est mise à
pied c'est pas une sanction la victime
peut l'être aussi si elle a besoin de
temps et d'être chez elle mais la
question pour le les mises en cause
c'est vraiment primordiale et c'est pas
du tout spontané dans les mises en place
de protection des employeurs enfin le
rôle des référents référentes
ils sont pas inclus dans les dans les
enquêtes voilà il y a un dispositif qui
est intéressant mais ça ça
par peur en fait des employeurs de voilà
de d'impliquer comme si d'impliquer les
référents ou des membres du CSE était un
frein à la résolution de du problème
j'ai peut-être déjà trop parlé je ne
sais pas j'ai encore des choses à dire
je crois mais
peut-être
oui vous dire parce que ce qui était
intéressant quand même c'est que les
organisations syndicales sur cette
thématique elles sont
elles sont elles sont elles sont soudées
et il y a eu un courrier faible puisque
vous il y avait quand même la question
des préconisations un courrier qui a été
fait de toutes les organisations
syndicales que je vous passerai en
novembre pour alerter la première
ministre donc
toutes les organisations syndicales un
revenaient sur les problématiques de
mise en place de de prévention des
enquêtes de la prise en compte des
victimes des problèmes de financement
des manques de personnel dédiés pour
pour régler et assez opérationnels pour
régler les problèmes de violence sexy
sexuelle et donc il y a des propositions
sur quatre dimensions la première les
organisations demandent une table ronde
multilatérale pour réaliser des bilans
en fait des dispositifs de 2018 c'est à
dire les références c'est super mais ça
marche pas donc pourquoi en ce moment ça
se négocie entreprise par entreprise
quand on peut avoir des accords où on
gagne un référent plus par lieu de
travail avec un portable un bureau une
formation en plus alors quand ça va être
la VFT c'est encore mieux mais en tout
cas avec des associations bien dédiées
donc il faut questionner ce dispositif
des référents et lui donner beaucoup
plus d'ampleur et de moyens
il y a un bilan à faire sur de la
négociation collective sur les violences
sexistes sexuelles notamment dans les
branches parce que ils devaient négocier
mais ont-elles négocié quelle visibilité
quel retour
un bilan quantitatif et qualitatif sur
la mise en place dans la fonction
publique des cellules d'écoute et des
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
victimes
parce qu'en soit il se passe des choses
intéressantes dans la fonction publique
mais et ça devrait être beaucoup plus
sécurisant pour les femmes de travailler
à cet endroit là mais pourquoi ça ne
l'est pas un bilan qualitatif et
quantitatif des dispositifs de
prévention existants
et puis il y avait une demande d'une
publication dans la fonction publique de
guide des outils statutaires pour lutter
contre les violences sexistes et ça ça a
été fait au mois de novembre maintenant
le problème qu'il y a c'est sa mise en
œuvre
en deuxième point on demande alors on
propose
les organisations syndicales proposent
par exemple que le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité
produise un baromètre annuel pour
évaluer le ressenti des salariés des
agents sur les violences sexistes et
sexuelles au travail pour donner des
indications objectives sur l'état de la
prise en compte du sujet donc ça c'est
une proposition
sur les recommandations nous dans le
privé et le public donc faire de la
prévention un sujet obligatoire de
négociation
étant donné que ce n'est pas fait on
propose sous sous peine de sanctions
pour les employeurs
mettre en place une obligation de
formation de tous les managers RH
représentants du personnel
voilà puisque ça rejoint les
recommandations
de vous mesdames mettre en place une
obligation de sensibilisation annuelle
sur les violences sexistes sexuelles
organiser sur le temps de travail et les
lieux de travail
en quatrième point donc il y a la
question de sécuriser l'emploi et la
carrière des victimes de violence
qu'elles aient ou non un lien avec le
travail pour faire lien avec les
violences conjugales alors le voilà les
premières
[Musique]
revendications proposition c'est nouveau
droit dont je vous parlais donc avec des
nouveaux jours notamment qui pourraient
du nombre de 10 pour pour leur garantir
du temps pour faire leur démarche
interdire le licenciement comme c'est le
cas pour les victimes de violences au
travail puisque on observe beaucoup la
double peine pour les femmes
victimes de violence renforcer les
possibilités d'action des référentes
harcèlement sexuels donc
je reviens pas et puis dans le privé
plus spécifiquement élargir les
prérogatives les moyens et la formation
des conseillers du salarié au
harcèlement sexuel pour permettre aux
salariés des entreprises sans IRP sans
institution représentative du personnel
d'être quand même accompagné face à
l'employeur
puisque pour l'instant les conseillers
du salarié peuvent être mobilisés sur
des problématiques de licenciement mais
pas de harcèlement sexuel donc on a des
nouveaux des nouvelles prérogatives à
penser pour ne pas laisser seuls les
femmes et puis augmenter le nombre et la
formation des inspections inspectrices
du travail voilà ça c'était les
recommandations merci merci beaucoup
madame j'avais du mal à vous arrêter
puisque l'intervenant de précédente
avait largement multiplié son temps par
deux donc ça veut je me voyais en
difficulté pour vous dire STOP merci à
vous quatre pour ces présentations
extrêmement précises et complémentaires
je vais me tourner vers les les
rapporteurs si elles souhaitent vous
poser des questions ou si la
présentation à
finalement a répondu oui la madame la
rapporteur Laurence Rossignol et merci à
vous quatre pour vos propos passionnants
exhaustifs j'avais quelques questions la
première mais peut-être ça n'existe pas
sur le problème de notre
frénésie immense de statistiques de
croisement voilà sur les
les effets sur la santé
de nombre d'arrêts maladies
des maladies psychologiques troubles
psychologiques bref tous les indicateurs
statistiques qu'on peut avoir
consommation de psychotropes entre le
fait d'avoir subi des violences
sexistes et sexuelle enfin notre sujet
c'est la santé des femmes on a bien
conscience que dans le maintien de
harcèlement il y a aussi des hommes
victimes de harcèlement mais bon on a un
sujet on s'y tient est-ce qu'on est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à nous
fournir la nature ça existe pas ça
existe pas
la deuxième question
concerne plutôt pour vous Madame manière
ce que vous avez évoqué le fait qu'il
est que des femmes avaient été obligé
d'aller au travail administratif pour
obtenir leur protection fonctionnelle
comment il faudrait réformer
l'accès à la protection fonctionnelle
pour leur épargner d'aller au tribunal
administratif puisque de toute façon les
malheureuses vont rentrer dans un
abominable tunnel
judiciaire administrates administratifs
administratif tribunaux pénal
prud'hommes enfin bref si on peut leur
en épargner et enfin j'ai 23e remarque
c'est plus une remarque une question
quand vous avez dit que était plus
exposé c'est vous était plus exposé aux
violences au travail en psychologique au
travail les précaires je comprends
célibataire et mère monoparentales ça ça
m'a attiré l'oreille si j'ose dire ce
qui veut dire qu'en fait qu'une femme
dotée d'un homme
serait protégé par le fait qu'il existe
un homme à l'extérieur comment vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme
explication à nous fournir je sais que
vous êtes des scientifiques donc si vous
n'avez pas d'explication vous n'allez
pas faire uniquement de l'intuition mais
est-ce que vous en avez une là dessus
alors est-ce qu'on prend toutes les
questions peut-être c'est peut-être plus
efficace donc qui souhaitent parmi les
rapporteurs interpellés interrogés
Laurence Cohen oui bonjour mesdames et
merci beaucoup effectivement vos propos
ont balayer
beaucoup de choses
moi c'est sur deux ou trois points où
j'aimerais avoir des éclaircissements et
c'est vrai que
en prolongement d'ailleurs des
questionnements de ma collègue Laurence
Laurence Rossignol
ce qui me semble intéressant et j'ai pas
je l'ai pas entendu c'est que souvent
quand il existe des affaires donc de
violences sexuelles et sexistes les
entreprises n'aiment pas du tout
que ce soit rendu visible
et donc la publicité si je puis dire je
sais pas comment appeler ça mais oui la
publicité de des faits qui se produisent
et très malvenu pour les entreprises et
ce que je me disais c'est est-ce que
vous avez
sur ce sujet là c'est à dire rendre
compte en fait et et
informer
des violences sexuelles et sexistes dans
telle ou telle entreprise pourrait les
rendre visibles c'est à dire que comme
vous l'avez dit je crois que vous l'avez
tout dit les violences sexuelles et
sexistes sont mises sur le tapis elles
sont invisibilisées le plus possible
ça rend service aux agresseurs mais pour
les femmes pour les femmes victimes ça
n'est pas évidemment pour les aider donc
le fait de rendre
visible de publier
sous forme de statistiques ou carrément
parce que je me souviens par exemple
quand il y avait eu des procès notamment
pense à une banque d'ailleurs qui avait
où on avait on avait rendu public les
avocats avaient rendu public
les choses l'entre enfin la banque avait
été très mal à l'aise mais je veux dire
que ça peut concourir à justement
visibilité les violences donc est-ce que
vous avez des éléments là-dessus ça
c'est mon ma première ma première
question la deuxième question est et je
trouve que Rafael manière
à la bien mis en exergue c'est
effectivement cet angle mort au niveau
des violences conjugales
c'est à dire que les violences
conjugales ont ces pertinemment qu'elles
ont des répercussions terribles sur la
santé mentale et physique des femmes
mais donc ces femmes sont pour la
majorité d'entre elles des salariés et
comment on peut
je veux dire arriver à exercer son
activité quand on subit des violences
sexuelles et sexistes dans son couple et
là c'est totalement
mis sous le boisseau et je voudrais
savoir quel
préconisations qu'elle recommandations
vous avez à partager avec nous pour
essayer justement de de faire reculer
cette cet angle mort et la dernière la
dernière question remarque c'est que moi
je suis très frappée par le fait que
d'une manière générale et c'est vrai
pour les vs
d'une manière générale
les gouvernements successifs les
pouvoirs publics ne font
très rarement le bilan des soit des
expériences qui sont menées soit des
politiques qui sont mises en place on
évalue pas ou peu les politiques qui
sont mises en place et je trouve que
dans le domaine donc des violences
sexuelles et sexistes c'est majeur parce
que justement il faudrait qu'on puisse
évaluer pour que les bonnes pratiques
soient partagées et soit
donc instauré dans toutes les
entreprises et je pense à l'expérience
par exemple la SNCF je ne la connaissais
pas enfin c'est le baromètre là c'est
intéressant pourquoi ça n'est pas élargi
à l'ensemble au moins des entreprises
publiques voilà mes trois questions
merci Annick rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames pour vos exposés très fournis
très documentés
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
est-ce que dans vos statistiques est-ce
que
Madame manière dans la dans la les cas
que vous avez rencontrés ou est-ce que
vous nous avez dit Madame manière que
toutes les toutes les femmes quel que
soit l'âge quel que soit leur situation
rencontrer au moins une fois dans leur
vie ces situations de violence de
sexisme
la délégation des droits aux femmes
l'année dernière a sorti un rapport
chaud sur la pornographie et notamment
sur l'accès qu'avait les jeunes à ces
sites pornos puisqu'on avait cité des
chiffres des enfants de 15 ans de 9 ans
qui avait librement accès à ces sites et
qui avait finalement une vision déformée
et de la sexualité des rapports plus
tard qui pourraient avoir avec les
femmes est-ce que il y a pas bien
longtemps j'ai entendu aussi une
statistique qui disait que les jeunes
les jeunes hommes étaient presque plus
violent avec les femmes que je dirais à
notre génération alors est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement tout ce qu'on
tousse qu'on voit tout ce qui est publié
peut peut jouer est-ce que vous pensez
que le fait qu'il n'y ait plus dans les
écoles puisque je crois que 13% des
écoles dans lesquelles il y a un
enseignement sur la vie affective
sexuelle est-ce que il faudrait pas
aussi à ce niveau là développer j'allais
dire l'éducation ou le respect entre les
hommes les femmes dans les deux sens
pour reprendre les propos de ma collègue
Laurence cohel quand elle parle de
bonnes pratiques alors est-ce que ça
pourrait être pour vous aussi un axe
dans la prévention puisque c'est aussi
je pense cet axe là qu'il faut viser
merci
merci beaucoup et la dernière rapporteur
à parler ce matin Marie Pierre Richer
merci mesdames pour pour vos
présentations moi je vais d'abord
rebondir sur une interrogation de
Laurence Rossignol puisqu'on parlait des
familles monoparentes etc madame dela je
sais que vous êtes intéressé notamment
aux femmes issues de la entre guillemets
de la classe dite populaire par rapport
à leur à leurs conditions de vie de
travail et d'emploi qui pour vous reste
aussi un des angle mort aujourd'hui de
la prise en compte de la santé des
femmes au travail donc je pense que ça
rejoint
l'interrogation de ma collègue donc si
vous pouviez développer un petit peu
parce qu'on a parlé de Me Too mais on a
mis tout et les dénonciations qu'il y a
eu à ma connaissance concerne une
certaine catégorie professionnelle et et
de femmes issues d'un certain milieu on
va dire donc oui donc je pense que ça ça
pourrait être aussi intéressante puisque
dans les questions que qui a posé la
Présidente il y avait des questions qui
concernait certains secteurs
professionnels sont-ils plus concernés
que d'autres et
il me semble évident sans avoir la
science infuse que pour certains métiers
précaires on va dire ou de première
ligne comme cela souvent été dit ces
derniers temps
l'impact est quand même plus difficile
pour dénoncer des actes des actes
sexistes ou sexuels il me semble
mesdames tout à l'heure que vous avez
dit que le monde du travail pouvait un
lieu ressources et à contrario il me
semble avoir entendu que c'était
difficile que ce soit un lieu ressources
donc si vous pouviez si vous pouviez
c'est ça si vous pouviez un peu
l'évoquer parce que hormis madame chaper
on a on a peu parlé de des médecins du
travail et pour les avoir pour en avoir
auditionné une récemment on sait que
c'est quand même primordial et puis
j'avais noté alors tout à l'heure je ne
sais plus qui les agresseurs savent ce
qu'ils font
les agresseurs savent ce qu'ils font et
en même temps je parlerai au niveau
générationnel de ces agresseurs parce
que à chaque heure vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure du côté paternalisme qui
englobe tellement de choses qui m'est un
petit peu le couvercle sur sur
la casserole à cocotte-minute plutôt je
vais pas et et en même temps est-ce que
vous pensez vraiment que c'est
générationnel et ce que le comportement
aujourd'hui de ces agressions sexistes
et sexuelles sont générationnels ou ou
alors est-ce qu'elles sont
elles sont sous couvertes de certaines
professions et puis pour conclure j'ai
noté ce qu'on retrouve dans beaucoup de
nos
auditions que l'on fait aujourd'hui
concernant la santé des femmes au
travail il y a quand même des mots qui
ressortent angle mort invisibilité déni
tabou comment on s'en sort
merci mesdames les rapporteurs je vais
demander à nos invités ce matin de faire
des réponses courtes consiste puisque
au milieu de 30 ce genre de truc on peut
pas du tout donc Madame la
vice-présidente et rapporteur Laurence
Rossignol sera excusée bien entendu
puisque la séance démarre à 10h30 et
d'ailleurs il y a d'autres auditions de
commission d'enquête aussi donc si vous
pouvez m'aideres faire court mais en
répondre quand même à mesdames les
rapporteurs et de toute façon dans tous
les cas vous pourrez nous envoyer des
compléments d'informations par mail si
vous le souhaitez
je vous laisse peut-être démarrer
puisque vous étiez les derniers
interpellés et peut-être démarrer
puisque la question faisait écho à celle
de la rapporteur Laurence Rossignol
celle de Marie-Pierre Richer comme ça au
moins la rapporteur entendra votre
réponse c'est d'autant plus par la
première question pour vous permettre
d'entendre la réponse vous posiez la
question des effets sur la santé et des
mesures donc Pauline l'a dit on a plus
de chiffres beaucoup plus de chiffres et
le problème c'est plus leur lisibilité
leur compatibilité savoir comment s'y
retrouver que de ne pas avoir de
chiffres un des phénomènes on peut
peut-être répondre moi sur événement de
vie et santé que j'ai coordonné pour le
ministère de la Santé toi sur le virage
un des phénomènes qui est apparu dans
cette enquête donc il y avait été
commandée par le cabinet de
Jean-François Mattei et reçu par
Roselyne Bachelot dans cette enquête
événement de vie et santé c'était que
les conséquences sur la santé alors
étonnamment quand on quand on fabrique
les chiffres et quand on est dans les
statistiques sur la santé physique
n'apparaissent pas très facilement
beaucoup de personnes que l'on voit très
victimes très chargées de vict ne
déclare pas des conséquences physiques
il y a véritablement des conséquences
sur la santé très marquées sur les sur
la santé mentale et moins sur les
conséquences physiques quand il y a un
ensemble de caractéristiques et donc là
je réponds aussi à votre deuxième
réponse c'est à dire que ce sont des
individus sociaux alors on essaie de
capturer ce qui se passe dans le travail
à la maison dans les espaces publics
mais la personne elle est plus ou moins
âgée en situation monowment parentale ou
pas et c'est le contexte de l'ensemble
des caractéristiques sociales c'est ce
qu'on voit apparaître dans ces enquêtes
qui fait que des violences entraînent
des conséquences sur la santé mentale
d'abord mais physique aussi avec un
ensemble de facteurs de vulnérabilité
alors ça c'est difficile à attraper et
une des grandes
[Musique]
un des grands défis des enquêtes depuis
l'envers en passant par événement de vie
et santé et en allant jusqu'à virage ça
a été justement par rapport à des
variables statistiques habituellement
observées professionnelles sociaux
professionnels le revenu etc par rapport
à ces variables qui ne sont pas
forcément opérantes à elle seule pour
identifier qui est victime de voir
comment elle se combine et donc là
l'analyse que l'analyse féministe
revendique comme intersectionnelle est
vraiment intéressantes de voir que ce
sont des profils de cumules de
difficultés sociales qui arrivent avec
des situations violences
madame manière parlait de moments de
vulnérabilité ou des personnes cumulent
ces problèmes de revenus d'emploi etc
pour virage peut-être donc juste pour
dire effectivement donc l'enquête virage
a aussi un chapitre consacré à la
question de la santé des effets des
violences de genre sur la santé donc je
vous vois il est en ligne vous pourrez
le voilà le consulter effectivement ça
objective certains des voilà certains
des effets notamment psychiques en
termes de dépression longue etc mais
aussi certains facteur qu'on pourrait
envisager comme des facteurs protecteurs
notamment le niveau de diplôme et
l'environnement social est encore une
fois donc il y a pas d'effets il y a pas
de de
réactions type en fait au violence
puisque il y a un ensemble aussi de
facteurs qui peuvent protéger les femmes
victimes de
répercussions à long terme de ces
violences tu finis sur tes questions et
puis je reprends après alors sur les
questions que vous avez posées sur
d'autres questions
sur l'invisibilité des violences
conjugales peut-être madame Cohen
[Musique]
dans la négation la délégation le
secrétariat des femmes a commandé une
étude à laquelle j'ai participé il y a
quelques années sur le chiffrage du coup
des violences conjugales et des
conséquences au moment de la loi des
conséquences sur les enfants
enfants et famille et donc j'ai repris
des chiffres exacts dans le montant
global du coup les violences conjugales
la violence dans le couple dans les
relations de couple c'était 3 milliards
600 millions et les arrêts de travail
liés à ces violences pour les femmes
représentent 108 millions environ
euh en 2016 ou 2014 les chiffres je
vérifiais donc sur l'actualité des
chiffres et pour les femmes et pour les
hommes c'était 3 millions 400
000 à peu près donc 510 millions pour
les femmes en termes d'arrêt de travail
le chiffre et là discuter de chiffrage
du coût des vidence conjugales en termes
de perte de gains de travail
c'est-à-dire de perte de productivité
perte de revenus etc c'est toujours à
double tranchant aussi puisque si on
signale aux employeurs que les personnes
qui vont être
à tendance de d'arrêt de travail répété
peuvent être effectivement des personnes
qui vont être mon productives ça peut
être évidemment un double tranchant sur
la fragilité vis-à-vis de l'employeur
donc ces situations là elles sont
particulièrement sensibles pour savoir
comment protéger ces personnes donc
Madame manière parlait de voilà 10 jours
de congés de plus
au contraire le droit du travail protège
une personne malade ne peut pas être
l'essentiel donc ces personnes là
devraient être particulièrement on
devrait être attentive à leur situation
pour que ces arrêts de travail à
répétition puisqu'on voit que 108
millions c'est quand même beaucoup
bénéficie d'une protection particulière
sur les jeux sur pour Madame Jacques
mais je prends rapidement donc du coup
les vous parliez des
questions que vous aviez c'était est-ce
que les jeunes hommes sont peut-être
presque plus violents vous avez dit donc
la question qu'on se pose toujours
voilà donc la question qu'on se pose
toujours sur l'âge et la violence alors
dans les enquêtes il y a une façon très
simple de répondre ou très simple
toujours mystérieuse malgré tout de
répondre à cette question c'est que
depuis les années 60 ou les enquêtes de
victimes ont commencé à être réalisés
aux États-Unis les jeunes générations
déclarent toujours plus de violence agit
et subies c'est à dire qu'on a toujours
eu l'impression depuis qu'on mesure ce
phénomène que les jeunes sont les jeunes
sont toujours plus violents et dans les
enquêtes on sait si on obtient des
résultats dans un cas statistique si on
obtient des résultats différents on sait
que on a quelque chose tout à fait
étrange on sait que très très
régulièrement on va trouver quelque
chose qui est qu'à la fois en termes de
violence agit déclarée ce qu'on relève
très peu dans la statistique en France
d'autres pays le fondamentage que nous
mais aussi en termes de violences subies
les jeunes déclarent plus violents et
donc ça on l'explique difficilement mais
par des effets combinés alors est-ce
qu'il y a un effet de génération ben non
parce que sinon quand ils arrivent à 50
ans pourquoi ils se mettrai à déclarer
moins de violence donc c'est pas des
générations qui sont violentes alors il
y a certainement un effet de génération
qui est la perception de la violence
donc il déclare aussi plus de violences
parce qu'ils ont un rapport à la
violence qui est peut-être différent
d'une autre enfin d'une autre et de ceux
qui ont avancé en âge il y a un effet
d'âge c'est-à-dire qu'il y a on l'a dit
au travail là jeûne et particulièrement
dans certains métiers dans une enquête à
laquelle j'ai participé sur les
violences dans la profession d'avocat
par exemple les jeunes avocats sont
extrêmement extrêmement exposés à des
dénigrements des violences sexistes avec
des différences hommes femmes absolument
gigantesques donc là il y a un effet
d'âge d'exposition à des comportements
des tensions et des violences et il y a
aussi un effet de mémoire c'est à dire
que quand on vieillit on fait malgré
tout même quand les événements ont été
très durs très difficiles à entraîner
tout un tas de conséquences on ne
déclare plus on oublie entre guillemets
alors ça diront sélectionne c'est-à-dire
on t en partie et on oublie
véritablement aussi où on ne reconnaît
plus comme violent les événements qu'on
aurait qu'on avait aussi vécu comme
violent éventuellement quand on était
plus jeune
sur les catégories sur meetou peut-être
que tu reprends les catégories sociales
effectivement c'est une question aussi
madame Richer
et le lieu de travail ressources et on
va peut-être laisser répondre la nacre
et la CGT sur le lieu de travail
ressources et oui
sur la question de la monopa oui oui je
fais cours je fais quoi sur la question
de la monoparie
la monoparlan parentalité mais c'est que
c'est un facteur de précarité pour les
femmes et un facteur aussi de
subordination de vulgaire habilités
c'est-à-dire que ça fait effectivement
partie de ces configurations ou des
violences peuvent s'exercer par le biais
de d'une multitude de facteurs donc on
peut parler d'intersectionnalité
effectivement mais c'est des facteurs
sociaux des facteurs de genre etc il a
besoin d'opérateurs fait partie de ces
facteurs-ci j'ai sur mes travaux sur les
femmes de classe populaire madame ce que
vous m'avez interpellé à ce propos il
s'agissait plutôt de travaux sur les
politiques publiques qui ciblent
certaines femmes aux dépend d'autres et
notamment il s'agissait de retour sur
des travaux de collecte sur les
politiques d'égalité professionnelle qui
tendent justement à cibler les femmes de
classe supérieure de classe moyenne et
supérieure plutôt que les femmes de
classe populaire et mes collègues donc
parlent de la notion d'égalité élitiste
à cet endroit qui de fait rendent
invisible aussi les conditions de vie
d'emploi et de travail des femmes de
classe populaire donc qui sont marquées
par des horaires atypiques le temps
partiel des salaires faible etc
mais c'est ces conditions là doivent
être nécessairement prises en compte
justement puisque c'est un facteur de
vulnérabilité et ces femmes là sont
sortes d'une certaine façon des radars
des pouvoirs publics
notamment dans le traitement des luttes
contre les violences et l'égalité
professionnelle
sur la question de l'angle mort des
violences conjugales effectivement donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est que en
faisant encore une fois un retour sur
l'action publique qui s'est développé
depuis les années 2000 sur les violences
faites aux femmes les violences
masculines en fin de compte les
violences conjugales elles tendent à
capter l'attention publique puisque
c'est le plus gros des lois et des
politiques publiques en fait ce qui se
sont qui s'est centrées sur ce type de
violence par contre effectivement quand
il s'agit de certaines sphères et
notamment du travail et bien là ça sort
de ça ça devient invisible au sens où
les conséquences de sa violence
deviennent invisibles et pour les femmes
en tant que sal il y a une espèce de
cloisonnement femme victime de violences
conjugales et femmes victimes de
violences au travail mais les frontières
sont pas poreuses alors même
qu'effectivement
la violence conjugale a nécessairement
des effets donc qui ont été rappelés par
nos collègues tout à l'heure
en terme d'estime de soi de confiance en
soi mais il y a aussi des effets autre
c'est à dire que si on comprend la
violence conjugale comme du contrôle
dans le couple ça veut dire aussi que ce
sont des femmes qui vont être isolées de
leurs collègues qui doivent rentrer à
des horaires très précis au risque
d'être victime d'insultes de dénigrement
etc c'est des femmes donc qui ne peuvent
pas participer au moment de sociabilité
nécessairement qui marque aussi
l'environnement de travail
j'étais surprise de savoir que vous
préconisiez donc enfin vous utilisez
l'exemple du canal là pour pour proposer
la recommandation de produire des droits
nouveaux pour faire une victime de
violence conjugales puisque pour ma part
j'avais travaillé sur les États-Unis
ou à l'occasion enfin à l'époque de la
mise en oeuvre des politiques de
workfair dans les années 90 des droits
spécifiques ont été accordés justement
aux femmes victimes de violences
conjugales en faisant en sorte que ces
femmes donc sortent du régime du
workfair pour bonne cause donc c'est
comme ça que c'est intitulé dans les
textes ce qui signifie que les femmes ne
sont pas obligées justement de chercher
un emploi sous un mois ou je sais plus
précisément et peuvent bénéficier de
droits sociaux le temps d'un suivi
notamment psychologique et d'un
accompagnement social le problème que je
vois là c'est encore celui qu'on
pointait avec ma collègue c'est le fait
d'une part que ces politiques sont
souvent mises en oeuvre dans un contexte
plus général de délitement de l'État
social et des droits sociaux pour tous
et toutes et donc il y a des niches de
protection qui peuvent être créés à ce
moment-là et par ailleurs la question
qui se pose aussi c'est à quelles
conditions ces femmes ont droit à des
droits spécifiques est-ce qu'il faut
porter plainte qu'est-ce qu'il faut
avoir déclaré des violences quel type de
violence et à quoi elles ont le droit
précisément donc c'est très ambigu je
pense ce type de politique publique je
termine très vite sur
j'ai envie de parler désolé
sur la question du manque de bilan
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
marque aussi l'action publique sur les
violences faites aux femmes et avec ma
collègue Gwenaëlle Perrier on mène une
enquête sur la question de des
formations sur les violences conjugales
en particulier donc notamment de la mise
en oeuvre des formations et en fait la
politique de formation qui est centrale
à la fois parce que c'est une demande de
tout le monde sur la question des
violences et à la fois parce que c'est
central dans les textes sur les gens
c'est notamment les violences conjugales
mais pas uniquement et bien en fait
c'est une politique strictement ou
quasiment strictement incantatoire c'est
à dire que la mi-prof a été mise en
place que des des contenus ont été
prodigués avec certains professionnels
ciblés comme les médecins etc mais
malgré tout on très peu de choses sur
les effets de cette politique de
formation on sait très peu de choses à
qui de fait elle est elle s'adresse et
comment elle est mise en oeuvre et là on
a vraiment un manque cruel de données
sur sur cette question alors même que
c'est absolument central et c'est
revendiqué par à peu près tous les
acteurs qui travaillent sur la question
des violences et dernière chose donc sur
la pornographie après je m'arrêterai là
j'ai essayé de parler très vite donc
effectivement la question de la
pornographie est vraiment encore une
fois
mis en lumière comme un des facteurs
problématiques sur l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes moi mon avis c'est
celui que partage pas mal de collègues
qui travaillent spécifiquement sur les
jeunes et là la sexualité c'est qu'on
peut pas isoler la question de la
pornographie de tout un contexte de
socialisation de genre notamment de la
compétition entre garçons les types de
masculinités les registres de
masculinité le mépris qui s'organisent à
la fois dans les interactions sociales
mais aussi qui entretenu par les
organisations et les institutions
et donc la pornographie en fait est sans
doute plus un épiphénomène que le
phénomène explicateur de cette division
du travail et des violences
sexistes sur les jeunes et le et les
violences je pense que vous citez en
fait la l'enquête qui a été publiée il y
a très peu de temps là par le HCE donc
c'est il me semble-t-il sexisme 2019 et
en fait effectivement ce que montre
cette enquête et je pense que c'est une
note d'espoir qu'il faut garder en tête
c'est aussi que les personnes enquêtées
sont plus conscientes du sexisme tel
qu'il existe qu'auparavant c'est à dire
qu'en fin de compte vu la formulation
des questions que j'ai regardé un peu
précisément on peut difficilement dire
s'il y a plus ou moins de violence il y
a plus de violences déclarées sans doute
mais c'est surtout que sans doute les
enquêter sont plus conscients de l'effet
du sexisme sur leur vie et ça c'est sans
doute intéressant à garder en tête pour
promouvoir des politiques d'égalité
ambitieux justement merci
merci beaucoup alors de plus en plus
court si vous plaît parce que il y a
d'autres séances également merci
beaucoup et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
sur violence conjugale je n'ai pas eu le
temps de le citer il y a eu un travail
intéressant fait entre la Fédération
nationale des CIDFF et fit femme une
femme un toit pardon sur violence
conjugale ils ont travaillé l'année
dernière à une méthodologie qui permet
un partenariat entre les CIDFF donc par
département et certaines entreprises
en partant du principe justement que si
la personne a été voir le CIDFF il y a
pas besoin de plaintes
l'employeur s'engage à des nouveaux
droits qui ne sont pas formalisés mais
l'employeur s'engage à une aide
formalisée à travers la possibilité
d'avoir des Chambres à Part hôtel par
exemple un aménagement
horaire un coffre-fort numérique pour
ses papiers personnels facilité ces
déplacements
euh une aide financière ponctuelle une
avance surprise et s'assurer qu'elle a
un compte voilà des choses comme ça ça
intéressant ça a été réfléchi l'année
dernière et mis en place avec certaines
entreprises je pense vraiment faut
regarder ce qui s'est fait là avec le
CIDFF il faut pousser là-dessus pour que
les lieux de travail au niveau des
violences conjugales soit des lieux
ressources et puis par rapport aux
déclarations accident de travail elles
sont il y a une il y a des sous c'est on
a un problème de sous-déclaration en
accident du travail des VSS en fait donc
ces problématique on n'a pas de
visibilité là-dessus et comment faire en
sorte de pas aller au tribunal
administratif quand la fonction la
protection fonctionnelle n'est pas
accordée je sais pas faut que je
réfléchisse avec mes camarades mais
globalement c'est un problème de culture
de la prévention et de et de la
protection qui se pose donc tous les
dispositifs globaux mis en place de
prévention devrait aider à ce que les
employeurs ne mettent pas de frein
merci beaucoup pour la concision madame
chaper si vous pouvez faire en deux
minutes PACS parce que nous avons et
nous vous avons laissé beaucoup de temps
tout à l'heure donc vous nous enverrez
éventuellement merci tout à fait juste
quelques points
sur la première question sur les
statistiques les arrêts le problème
c'est que on a déjà pas de données
sexuées sur les arrêts maladie sur les
consommations les addictions selon le
sexe du coup très compliqué en tout cas
au niveau des entreprises au niveau de
la CNAM d'avoir des éléments
sur la question des mers isolés c'est
simplement une observation que nous
avions faites dans ce restaurant que
cela concernait le harcèlement sexuel
concerné les apprentis et les mères
isolées sur la question de la publicité
oui les entreprises en ont peur donc on
ne peut que recommander le type de
baromètre que fait la SNCF voir
d'intégrer dans l'index égalité un
élément sur
un indicateur sur le nombre de cas de
harcèlement d'agressions sexuels et il
est vrai que la mesure dans les risques
psychosociaux a permis de faire de faire
progresser sur l'angle mort des
violences conjugales c'est l'entreprise
SNCF qui a beaucoup travaillé
effectivement avec l'association fit et
le CIDFF donc par les Raphaël manière
sur la question du bilan
il est vrai que le rôle des référents
n'est pas évident il a été il a été non
défini par la loi c'est l'objet du
projet sur lequel l'anacte va travailler
puisque nous allons faire un retour
d'expérience avec 20 référents dans le
secteur privé et 20 consultants qui
accompagnent des entreprises pour en
tirer des éléments d'outillage un petit
peu plus
conséquent sur la proposition de
travailler au niveau des écoles oui bien
sûr nous avons été sollicités pour
travailler avec un collège bon alors que
nous travaillons dans le monde du
travail mais nous allons relayer cette
demande déjà au niveau du collège ces
questions se posent sur la question des
tenues sexuelles
sur la dernière point sur les ressources
oui l'entreprise a des ressources il y a
beaucoup de facteurs de risque mais il y
a aussi des ressources des ressources
liées à sa structuration les
représentants du personnel les CSE les
droits des CSE et Madame manière on a
parlé c'est aussi le fait d'avoir des
collectifs de travail des espaces de
discussion sur le travail c'est la
politique de prévention des risques qui
est quand même assez exigeante en France
même si le document unique n'est réalisé
qu'à 50% c'est la politique égalité
quand même de plus en plus d'entreprises
aussi sont mises ça c'est de la
prévention primaire et en prévention
secondaire les entreprises ont des
moyens elles ont des budgets pour former
et du coup nous nous estimons que les
violences sexistes sexuelles oui
faisaient l'objet font l'objet d'un
dîner de tabou comme le faisait les RPS
les risques psychosociaux il y a 15 ans
voilà je m’arrêterai là merci beaucoup
madame chaper et bien écoutez merci
mesdames pour toutes vos informations je
vous renouvelle cet appel à nous envoyer
éventuellement des précisions ou des
documents que vous souhaiteriez nous
envoyer je remercie mesdames les
rapporteurs et les collègues Martin
fille notamment qui étaient présents
avec nous ce matin en séance et je une
dernière question mesdames les membres
de la délégation il y avait pas d'homme
désolé ce matin n'a pas été n'était pas
respectée
nous avions organisé un colloque le 9
mars dernier femme et ruralité la parole
aux élus de nos territoires et j'ai
besoin de votre autorisation pour lancer
la publication à la fois sur le net et
également peuvent sous format papier
donc nous autorisons nous à publier ces
éléments
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vous
souhaite à tous et à toutes une belle
journée merci Madame